[Musique]
étranger
avec l'atterrissage d'une sonde sur la comète 67d
l'agence spatiale européenne a réalisé
la mission spatiale la plus complexe du
siècle mais tout n'a pas été
selon le plan
[Musique]
les premiers jours de la technologie Rocket étaient
parsemé d'échecs spectaculaires
Adversaires de la guerre froide, l’Union soviétique
et les États-Unis étaient pressés de
acquérir la technologie des missiles pour livrer
la bombe à hydrogène nouvellement développée
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale, l'Allemagne avait
travaillé sur des fusées balistiques
bon nombre de leurs premières tentatives avaient également
n'a pas réussi
en octobre 1942, l'équipe allemande dirigée par
Verna Von Braun avait un prototype fonctionnel
quand les armes sont devenues massives
des attaques de production V2 ont été lancées en
Grande-Bretagne et Belgique
[Musique]
avec la chute de Berlin, la Russie et
L'Amérique était désireuse de mettre la main sur
Technologie V2 et techniciens allemands
capturés à la fin de la guerre étaient
vital pour les premiers programmes de fusées de
des deux côtés
[Musique]
dans les années 1950, l'Union soviétique a commencé à travailler
avec des moteurs groupés et le R7 le
Le précurseur des Sawyers d'aujourd'hui a émergé
la nouvelle R7 comportait deux étages centraux
flanqué de quatre boosters une configuration
c'est encore utilisé aujourd'hui
il pourrait livrer un lourd thermonucléaire
Ogive vers une cible en Amérique du Nord
et la R7 était suffisamment puissante pour mettre un
satellite en orbite
[Musique]
le 4 octobre 1957, l'Union Soviétique
a lancé un satellite de 83 kilogrammes appelé
Spoutnik
tout a changé
il a orbité autour de Spoutnik et a émis un bip
qui pourrait être capté par la radio
passé au-dessus
L’Amérique a pris cela comme un défi direct
les États-Unis avaient deux candidats proches
lancer un satellite une équipe de l'armée avec
son missile maritime Jupiter dirigé par l'allemand
Ferna von Braun, ingénieure V2
et une équipe navale appelée Vanguard
par rapport au Jupiter 1 de l'armée
Vanguard n’a pas encore fait ses preuves, mais
parce que les États-Unis étaient réticents à s'appuyer
sur Von Brown et son équipe allemande
Vanguard a été chargé de lancer
Le premier satellite américain
mais les Russes ont eu une nouvelle surprise
un mois avant la date de lancement de Vanguard
et à peine un mois après celui de Spoutnik
vol, un autre R7 était sur le pad
c'était le lancement de Spoutnik 2.
et cette fois il y avait un passager
terrier appelé Leica
[Musique]
Aux États-Unis, pendant la guerre froide, la paranoïa était
devenir extrême pour attirer le peuple américain
le long de
théâtres
la pression montait sur l'Avant-garde
une équipe pour sauver l'American Pride
en plus des journalistes et
photographes couvrant l'événement
a annoncé le lancement depuis Cap Canaveral
serait
vivant
[Musique]
c'était une humiliation nationale
et ici Pickering Van Allen s'amuse Brown
L'équipe de Von Brown a reçu le feu vert
en quelques semaines, le groupe a développé un satellite
nommé Explorer, celui qui était une fraction
la taille de Spoutnik quatre états Jupiter
C contrairement à Spoutnik qui vient d'emporter un
émetteur radio Explorer One contenu
une actualité scientifique du jour a
a montré que celui de Juno était un modèle modifié
Redstone Rocket avec une tige rotative
mettre en scène une technique simple imaginée par Von
Brown pour avoir supprimé une dernière étape
système de guidage
13h48 les trois dernières étapes sont fixées
tourner au décollage pour se guider
fins
c'était simple mais ça signifiait que Juno
n'a pas pu livrer sa charge utile avec précision
sur une orbite circulaire
mais les Américains étaient pressés
[Musique]
plus tard en 1958, le président Eisenhower
a créé une agence spatiale dirigée par des civils
qui a absorbé une grande partie du missile de l'armée
unité ainsi que le programme Vanguard, il
serait connue sous le nom de NASA
en 1959, la NASA a sélectionné sept astronautes
pour un programme spatial habité qui ne
existait sur papier
La Russie avait également choisi un cosmonaute
noyau et travaillait pour mettre le premier
l'homme en orbite
la recherche soutenue par une énorme ingénierie
les budgets devenaient une guerre par procuration entre
les superpuissances et jusqu'à présent le Soviétique
L'Union gagnait
mais la NASA avait hérité du programme X-15
un avion propulsé par fusée qui était
fournir des données précieuses sur le vol
contrôle aux frontières du
atmosphère
le X-15 est revenu au sol
sans électricité et sans techniques
réunis ici ont bénéficié à la NASA
quand la navette spatiale était là
développement
l'un des pilotes du X-15 rejoindrait la NASA
dans sa deuxième promotion d'astronautes dont
le nom était Neil Armstrong
mais les Soviétiques allaient de l'avant après
plusieurs incidents, ils en avaient rendu une paire
des chiens belka et Stroker en toute sécurité de
l'espace et en 1961, ils se préparaient à
mettre un homme en orbite le 12 avril
1961, un jeune pilote de l'Air Force grimpe
dans son vostok une capsule
il s'appelait Youri Gagarine
[Musique]
le premier homme dans l'espace de l'Union Soviétique
avait établi le record le plus prestigieux à ce jour
les États-Unis possédaient un vaisseau spatial
Capsule de mercure mais ils avaient besoin d'un
un booster plus lourd pour le mettre en orbite
Explorer 1 avait été soulevé par une pierre rouge
dérivé et premier Mercure sans pilote
les vols utiliseraient également le Redstone
Alan Shepard devait devenir le leader américain
premier vol spatial habité au sommet d'un
redstone mais ce serait une sous-orbitale
vol, le nouvel Atlas, plus puissant,
mettre le premier astronaute en orbite et
jusqu'à présent, aucun des lanceurs ne fonctionnait
de manière fiable
enfin en mai 1961 après un chimpanzé
avait testé le Mercury Redstone
combinaison Alan Shepard deviendrait
le premier Américain à voler dans l'espace
[Musique]
Instagram
le vol a duré 15 minutes
Shepard et sa capsule Freedom Seven
ont été récupérés à 480 kilomètres du
côte de Floride plus tard ce mois-là
Le président américain nouvellement élu
Kennedy a engagé son pays dans une
atterrir sur la lune
[Musique]
non pas parce qu'ils sont faciles mais parce que
ils sont durs, c'était le début de
la Course à l'Espace la plus concertée
effort scientifique dans l'histoire
depuis le XVIIIe siècle lorsque Guillaume
Herschel a découvert les télescopes d'Uranus
ont connu des augmentations plus importantes
la taille nous permettait de voir plus loin
objets mais ce n'est qu'Edwin
Hubble que nous avons appris à quelle distance
certains de ces objets ont été
on pensait que notre galaxie était
l'univers jusqu'en 1924, lorsque Hubble
prouvé que nous n'étions qu'un des
d'innombrables galaxies dans l'univers
mais les astronomes atteignaient le
limite technique de leurs instruments non
à cause de leur taille mais à cause de
distorsion de l'atmosphère terrestre
en 1946, l'astronome Lyman Spitzer
a proposé un télescope en orbite au-dessus du
voile déformant de l'atmosphère
c'était une idée folle des années à l'avance
la capacité technique de l'humanité, mais elle
a été construit et le télescope spatial nommé
après qu'Edwin Hubble ait été en orbite
depuis 1990.
aucun instrument n’a contribué à lui seul
plus à notre compréhension du
univers que le télescope spatial Hubble
mais ça n'a pas été simple
quelque chose d'aussi complexe qu'un système autonome
télescope situé dans les conditions difficiles
l'environnement de l'espace a besoin d'être régulier
maintenance et ce n'était possible que
à cause de la navette spatiale et de ses
capacité à servir de plateforme de travail
sans la navette spatiale et ses
missions d'entretien régulières Hubble's
insuffisance de conception initiale et une série
des valeurs des composants l'auraient quitté
comme un déchet spatial très coûteux
après le déploiement par Discovery du
Télescope spatial en 1990, il y en avait quatre
les vols de maintenance ultérieurs ont été Hubble
à la fois réparé et mis à niveau sur ces derniers
missions au passage du véhicule
la zone de pression dynamique maximale
Atlantis Houston pas de cire avec la navette
maintenant retiré du service, il y aura
plus de maintenance en orbite
composants prêts pour le dernier Hubble
La mission de maintenance comprenait de nouveaux gyroscopes
lespiles
outils d'astronaute de capteur de guidage fin
matériel de soutien
un nouvel anneau d'accueil
les systèmes porteurs
et deux nouveaux instruments
mais construire le matériel et l'emballer
car le vol en orbite n'était qu'une partie de
la préparation
au laboratoire de flottabilité neutre de la NASA à
Maquettes de Houston de la navette
La baie de charge utile et le Hubble étaient
disponible pour la formation exhaustive
les astronautes nécessaires
les conditions doivent correspondre à celles que le
les astronautes expérimenteront en orbite
les problèmes rencontrés dans la piscine sont
résolu avant que l'équipe ne s'envole
en 2004, lorsqu'une alimentation électrique a fait exploser Hubble
a perdu son spectrographe d'imagerie
ing ce composant était quelque chose de jamais
envisagé par les concepteurs du télescope
il fallait donc des techniques et des outils spéciaux
être développé
Dade s'est approché de tout le matériel
emballé dans des conteneurs d'expédition spéciaux
pour le transfert vers le site de lancement où
la prochaine phase de l'opération a commencé
le 2 mars 2004, un Aryan 5 a explosé
au départ de Kuru en Guyane française
transportait la sonde Rosetta, l'un des
les missions spatiales les plus ambitieuses à ce jour
lancé
récemment, il est sorti d'un
hibernation de trois ans
quand j'ai entendu pour la première fois l'idée de Rosetta, je
je pensais que ce serait extrêmement difficile
nous n'avons jamais envoyé de vaisseau spatial vers un
comète
sa mission est de Rendez-vous avec un
comète et elle a dû parcourir un complexe
trajectoire de vol pour y arriver
les précédentes sondes spatiales lointaines ont transporté
alimentations radio-isotopiques mais Rosetta
est conçu avec des panneaux solaires, il
porte un Lander appelé filet
le parcours suivi par Rosetta a
je l'ai fait passer par Mars, puis je suis revenu
Terre pour obtenir l'aide de la
les champs gravitationnels de la planète
la sonde a survolé Mars à seulement 250
kilomètres initialement destinés à rencontrer
Les retards dans le lancement de la comète Vertanan signifiaient un nouveau
La comète devait être ciblée
[Musique]
Rosetta a atteint une distance maximale de
le Soleil de 780 millions de kilomètres prenant
au-delà de l'orbite de Jupiter
lors de sa croisière Rosetta photographiée
astéroïdes Steins et Leticia
[Musique]
à partir de mai dernier une série de Thruster
Les brûlures étaient surveillées par des membres du
L'équipe de la mission Rosetta
le premier des trois Burns majeurs a pris
place avec Rosetta 500 millions
à des kilomètres
18 kilogrammes de carburant et a duré 7 heures
et 16 minutes
il a mis Rosetta en phase avec son
Cible comète Turiamov Jerry Simenko
sur plusieurs mois 10 séparés
Des corrections étaient nécessaires et en août
la sonde faisait environ une centaine
kilomètres de la comète
les membres de l'équipe ont commencé à voir exactement ce
bande dessinée 67p churium de jerusimanco avait l'air
comme
ces images sont générées par ordinateur
Récréation basée sur les premières images de
la comète
comme c'est encore loin du soleil non
la queue s'est encore développée
c'est seulement quand tu te rapproches du
Soleil, cette comète, activité, ce matériau
commence à devenir actif et c'est
dégazage puis le commentaire
tailleurs formés et c'est ce que nous
on voit normalement dans le ciel
la petite Rosetta devra être à un très
faible vitesse relative pour orbiter autour de lui
actuellement la sonde effectue
une série de manœuvres triangulaires pour
suivre la comète
étranger
images relayées par la navigation de Rosetta
les caméras surprennent les scientifiques qui
m'attendant à un objet beaucoup plus lisse où
des traces de glace en surface étaient apparentes
cinq zones d'atterrissage possibles
le site J a été sélectionné pour le filet Lander
il avait la meilleure combinaison d'énergie solaire
éclairage et accès radio au
Vaisseau mère Rosetta
la forme de la comète est définitivement une
un peu inattendu, je le considère en même temps
temps fantastique c'est un objet unique sur
de l'autre côté, je suppose qu'il y en a
des maux de tête pour trouver le bon site d'atterrissage
à cause de cette forme inhabituelle
et il a été libéré à une distance de
20 kilomètres, sa chute de quatre heures était
chronométré pour qu'il arrive au
zone prévue en tenant compte de la
période de rotation de 12 heures de la comète
les filets posent trois pattes à
conçu pour ancrer l'engin au contact
avec la surface
sur Terre, la terre pèse cent
kilogrammes mais bien que la comète 67p soit la
taille d'une montagne, sa gravité est très
léger
le filet de surface de la comète a un poids
équivalent à un morceau de papier
c'est un problème que les vis des jambes et un
les petits harpons d'ancrage ont été conçus pour
surmonter
en plus un petit Thruster au sommet
du Lander pousserait l'engin vers le bas
au contact de la surface
c'est comme ça que ça devait se passer
mais les scientifiques qui ont dû attendre un
message relayé via Rosetta étaient
confus
pour qu'un signal de confirmation atteigne
Contrôle de mission à Darmstadt
il y a eu une fête
mais après des heures d'analyse, c'est devenu
évident que les dispositifs d'ancrage avaient
tout a échoué et la sonde a rebondi
reculer jusqu'à une hauteur d'un kilomètre
après le premier contact, à moins d'un mètre de
le filet d'ellipse d'atterrissage prévu
s'est finalement immobilisé au pied d'un
falaise
il fonctionnait bien et renvoyé
des images de ses environs, y compris celle-ci
photo de son pied coincé contre
la falaise
ce n'était pas un bon endroit pour le métier
les panneaux solaires ne recevront qu'un nombre limité
lumière du soleil
alors que sa batterie en avait encore assez
charge, le Lander a été invité à forer
un échantillon de surface, l'analyser et le relayer
les résultats de la machine mère Rosetta
ça s'est bien passé mais les batteries du filet
sont maintenant plats, on espère qu'à mesure que
comète s'approche du Soleil, l'engin va
recevoir suffisamment de lumière pour recharger son
source de courant
pendant ce temps, la sonde Rosetta
continuez à suivre la comète 67p pendant qu'elle prévient
et développe sa queue caractéristique
[Musique]
merci
depuis les premiers jours de la fusée
lance des milliers de satellites
été livré en orbite terrestre
aujourd'hui une prise de conscience des débris orbitaux
désigne les satellites à la fin de leur
les vies sont réglées sur un cours qui verra
ils brûlent dans l'atmosphère
[Musique]
mais de nombreux satellites restent en altitude et
étages supérieurs contenant du carburant non brûlé
continuera à dériver parfois avec
des conséquences alarmantes
[Musique]
un nuage de débris orbitaux a été
s'accumulant autour de notre planète, cela a
de sérieuses implications pour le nouveau satellite
lancements
Esa suit les plus gros morceaux de ceci
débris orbitaux pour voir où le courant
les satellites risquent d'entrer en collision
les stations au sol sont importantes dans
déterminer les paramètres orbitaux de
satellites défunts qui ne peuvent plus
communiquer
seulement sept pour cent des objets surveillés
sont des satellites fonctionnels
[Musique]
sur les 16 à 17 000 objets que nous pouvons
suivre depuis les stations au sol là-haut juste
environ 1 000 engins spatiaux opérationnels
le reste sont des vestiges de l'espace passé
activités aériennes et plus de la moitié
de ces objets en fait des fragments
fragments de collisions hors orbite
récemment et aussi des fragments de
explosions en orbite
les satellites les plus à risque sont
ceux sur les orbites nord-sud comme le
Satellites d'observation de la Terre les traces
de ces engins convergent vers les pôles et
c'est là que la probabilité la plus élevée de
une collision existe
il y a déjà eu quatre grands
collisions en orbite terrestre basse
l'impact le plus grave a été celui
entre un satellite iridium et un
défunt satellite Cosmos en février
2009.
ils sont entrés en collision à une vitesse relative de
environ 42 000 kilomètres par heure
créant 2 000 pièces supplémentaires de
débris
ce nuage de débris a continué à
répartis sur différentes orbites polaires
selon le droit spatial international
responsabilité pour tout débris ou
le satellite abandonné reste avec le
les réglementations des propriétaires exigent de nouveaux satellites
transporter suffisamment de carburant pour entrer dans une zone en décomposition
orbite en fin de vie utile
projets visant à désorbiter des objets dangereux
sont en cours d'élaboration mais ils sont très
cher
[Musique]
Non
belle vallée
étranger
[Musique]
Le système de lancement est le résultat de plus de
50 ans d'évolution progressive c'est le
la fusée la plus fiable au monde ayant
volé plus de 1700 fois et
les utilisateurs commerciaux l'adorent
dans les années 1950, lorsque l'URSS et les États-Unis
sont devenues des superpuissances d’après-guerre
la technologie des missiles balistiques a été poussée
Centre de la scène
ouais, les premiers résultats étaient fréquents
catastrophique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce que l'Amérique pourrait stationner des missiles
en Europe occidentale, ils se sont développés
armes à courte portée
mais l'Union soviétique a dû développer le
capacité de livrer une arme nucléaire lourde
charge utile de la Russie vers les États-Unis
le R7 Sim Yorker a été le premier au monde
missile balistique intercontinental
cela a également donné à l'URSS la possibilité de
lancer un satellite en orbite un énorme
avantage dans les premières années de l'espace
vol
Les Américains ont été alarmés lorsque leur
l'ennemi communiste a commencé à créer de l'espace
des disques qui dépassaient de plusieurs années leur
technologie du marché libre
en 1958, le président Eisenhower a créé
La NASA va consolider l'espace américain
effort dans une agence civile et le
l'équipe nouvellement constituée a commencé à travailler dans un
dépêchez-vous
le sentiment dominant aux États-Unis était
ils étaient bien derrière les Russes
[Musique]
Esser a absorbé l'homme de l'US Air Force
dans l'espace, le programme le plus tôt a été renommé
projet Mercure
Les ingénieurs ont commencé à travailler sur un Space en titane
Capsule qui pourrait nourrir un humain
le vide de l'espace et résister aux
Chaleur torride de la rentrée
en tant que futurs astronautes 110 militaires
les pilotes d'essai répondaient aux exigences de base de la NASA
prérequis et ont été invités à participer
le processus de sélection rigoureux conçu
pour choisir l'équipe du projet Mercury
en plus d'être un pilote de jet qualifié
avec 1500 heures de vol, les candidats devaient
avoir une formation d'ingénieur et être
moins de 40 ans au moment de la sélection
mais certains pilotes étaient réticents à
bénévole ayant le sentiment que les astronautes
faire peu de vol en servant simplement de
élaborations glamour
[Musique]
quand les sept premiers astronautes furent
présentés lors d'une conférence de presse, ils
étaient salués comme des stars de cinéma, c'était en 1959
et le seul être vivant à avoir
qui tournait autour de la Terre était un chien russe
[Musique]
on savait que l'Union soviétique était
travaille pour envoyer un homme dans l'espace mais la NASA
était déterminé qu'un Américain
arrivés en premier alors ils ont commencé à modifier
Le booster Redstone éprouvé bien qu'il
Je n'avais pas le pouvoir de lancer un homme
en orbite un plan pour réaliser une série de
de courts vols suborbitaux pour tester leurs
technologie
Le premier vol orbital habité de la NASA serait
utilisez le missile sm65 Atlas beaucoup plus gros
ICBM qui était en cours de modification pour transporter
la capsule Mercure
la fiabilité était un problème
[Musique]
en septembre 1959 lors de l'essai statique
d'un atlas une panne de turbo pompe
a déclenché un arrêt complet
[Musique]
mais le feu a persisté, la pompe endommagée a été
fuite d'oxygène
[Musique]
les dommages au coussin ont mis sept mois à
réparation
faisaient exploser une issue de secours
le système a été développé
Howard au sommet de la capsule abritait un petit
mais puissante fusée à combustible solide qui
pourrait éloigner le vaisseau spatial d'un
Échec catastrophique
pour tester le système Escape un nouveau booster
connu sous le nom de Little Joe a été construit, c'était
basé sur la technologie existante et moins cher
que d'utiliser une fusée à grande échelle
étranger
la tour de secours a été testée sur le
sol à contrainte dynamique maximale et à
très haute altitude
une séquence complexe d'événements a dû
se produit automatiquement pour renvoyer le
capsules en toute sécurité vers un océan Splashdown
cela poserait des problèmes plus tard
étape de test
[Musique]
la capsule elle-même a dû être testée et
les nouveaux astronautes ont chacun reçu un
Domaine de spécialisation
Les ingénieurs obtiendraient une contribution directe de
les gens qui piloteraient le Mercury
vaisseau spatial
[Musique]
Centre de recherche de Langley, le nouveau
les astronautes ont été formés aux concepts
comme le rétrofire et la rentrée
les Mercury 7 avaient tous de l'ingénierie
diplômes et même à ce stade leur
les commentaires conduisaient à une refonte de
systèmes de contrôle des capsules
[Musique]
des simulateurs ont été développés qui ont donné un
astronaute la sensation d'une chute
capsule permettant à l'équipe de gagner
expérience avant de voler
[Musique]
sur des vols spéciaux, ils ont eu un avant-goût
Gravité zéro
vers la fin des années 1960, l'équipe Mercury
était sur le point d'effectuer des essais en vol à grande échelle.
la première combinaison Mercury Redstone serait
effectuer un vol suborbital sans pilote vers
qualifier le système
Alan Shepard avait été sélectionné pour réaliser
le premier vol habité et il semblait que c'était le cas
serait le premier homme dans l'espace
[Musique]
connu sous le nom de mr1, ce premier projet Mercury
le véhicule a été assemblé au Cap
complexe de lancement de Canaveral 5.
tester la commande de vol automatisée
système de lancement et de suivi ainsi que
procédures de récupération
le système d'abandon automatisé des capsules a
un élément de sécurité vital serait également
testé
[Musique]
on l'appellerait les quatre pouces
faire voler les moteurs d'appoint brusquement
arrêté et la tour de secours a été
largué comme programmé à la fin de
la phase Boost cela a déclenché le
déploiement des parachutes quittant le
capsule en place Au sommet Le plein de carburant
Pierre rouge
le problème avait été causé lorsque l'alimentation
bouchons à la base du Redstone
désengagé dans le mauvais ordre a
Le technicien avait déposé un contact pour
l'adapter
un nouveau booster a été transporté par avion pour remplacer
celui qui est endommagé
la même capsule sera utilisée pour le
deuxième tentative mais il fallait que ce soit
Remis à neuf
les connexions électriques qui avaient
déclenché l'arrêt du moteur étaient
repensé et le séquençage automatisé
pour avoir largué la tour de secours avait
été repensé
la coupure du moteur principal ne pouvait que déclencher
la libération de la tour
137 secondes après le décollage
le vol retardé maintenant connu sous le nom de mr-1a
a été lancé le 19 décembre
a volé plus haut que prévu mais a été
autrement Flawless, mais la NASA avait perdu un
mois dans leur précipitation pour mettre un homme
l'espace d'abord
un chimpanzé ferait le prochain vol
Les ingénieurs n'étaient pas sûrs de risquer
un astronaute quand le booster était encore
voler trop haut
le chimpanzé numéro 65 connu sous le nom de Ham volerait
avant qu'un humain et les astronautes soient
pas heureux
le vol était désigné MR2 et s'il
tout s'est bien passé, Alan Shepard serait le prochain
[Musique]
mais les choses ne se sont pas bien passées et je suis hyperactif
la pompe a épuisé l'oxygène liquide du moteur
trop vite et lorsque la pression du moteur
a laissé tomber le système Escape et s'est activé
soulever la capsule de Ham à une altitude de
253 kilomètres bien plus haut que ce qui avait été auparavant
prévu
parce que le système Escape s'était activé
les capsules rétro Rockets avaient été
largué, ce qui signifie que le vaisseau spatial
le retour balistique sur Terre ne pourrait pas avoir lieu
ralenti
Ham l'astrochimpanzé a connu plus de
14 G lors de la rentrée
ensuite, une vanne s'est ouverte tôt et le
la capsule a perdu de la pression
enfin quand la capsule s'est écrasée
200 kilomètres au-delà du point du plan,
le sac d'impact a été déchiqueté et la chaleur
le bouclier avait percé des trous dans la capsule
base l'inondant d'eau de mer
le jambon avait survécu protégé à l'intérieur du
petit compartiment qui servait de
sa combinaison spatiale mais débat pour savoir si
le système était prêt à prendre une
L'astronaute a commencé
un vol supplémentaire pour régler les bugs
le booster Redstone était prévu
au même moment, la NASA craignait
Un booster Atlas beaucoup plus grand en état de préparation
pour les vols orbitaux
développé comme missile de livraison d'armes
l'atlas était également utilisé pour lancer
satellites son acier inoxydable très fin
la peau le rendait très léger mais c'était aussi
fragile et ses premiers résultats en matière de sécurité étaient
pas bon
[Musique]
lors de son premier lancement portant un mannequin
Capsule de mercure, la peau fine de l'atlas
ce serait renforcé pour tous
vols ultérieurs
[Musique]
il n'avait pas été annoncé publiquement que
Alan Shepard ferait le premier
Vol Mercury mais les membres de l'équipe étaient
de plus en plus confiant qu'il le ferait
devenez le premier homme dans l'espace
mais son vol a été reporté plusieurs fois
fois un remplacement pour le booster
nécessaire pour le test de développement supplémentaire
a mis du temps à arriver, un lancement original en
Février 1961 a été reporté à mars
puis jusqu'en mai
en avril, l'équipe soviétique a eu encore un autre
surprise après un adieu sincère
Le colonel Youri Gagarine se prépare à entrer
son vaisseau spatial de Rostock
la fuite et l'identité de Gagarine avaient
été un secret bien gardé sans aucun
de ses collègues cosmonautes étant au courant
qui devait faire la première tentative
[Musique]
l'engin fonctionnerait automatiquement
Avec Youri Gagarine devant entrer dans un
code pour déverrouiller les commandes si c'est le cas
nécessaire
[Musique]
Gagarine a effectué une orbite complète du
terre et est revenu sain et sauf, il n'était qu'en
contact radio en survolant la Russie
le premier cosmonaute était un héros le premier
un vol spatial habité a capturé le monde
attention et cela a surpris le Soviétique
Union autant que quiconque Le Souriant
Gagarine est devenu un atout majeur pour son
pays
[Musique]
les dirigeants soviétiques en voulaient plus et
le financement gouvernemental pour l'espace a été assuré
un groupe n'est pas content de Gagarine
vol ou les astronautes de Mercure
alors qu'ils en recevaient beaucoup
la publicité, tout ce qu'ils avaient fait jusqu'à présent était
former
Alan Shepard avait raté l'occasion
être le premier et son court sous-orbital
le vol serait un anti-climax après le
Triomphe soviétique
aux petites heures du 5 mai 1961
Shepard est arrivé chez Cap Canaveral
complexe de lancement 5.
un lanceur de redstone attendait surmonté
avec une capsule de Mercure Shepherd qu'il a nommée
Liberté sept
il a été nommé fouille au Soviet
Le système politique de l'Union
Les médias américains avaient qualifié Gagarine
fuite comme un coup de propagande plutôt que
une réussite scientifique
[Musique]
l'horloge a commencé oui monsieur en train de lire
tu es fort et clair après un délai Liberté
sept ont décollé du vol et sont montés à
une hauteur de 187 kilomètres PSI, l'oxygène est
allez quelle belle vue
à plusieurs moments, Shepard a pris le manuel
contrôle de son métier mais c'était fini
rapidement avec un vol qui ne dure que 15
minutes et 22 secondes
Freedom 7 s'est écrasé dans l'Atlantique
au large des côtes de Floride via Shepherd
n'avait pas mis en orbite le projet Mercure avait mis
un homme dans l'espace et l'Amérique était désireuse de
rattraper
l'idée qu'il y avait une course entre
les superpuissances devenaient tout aussi
lancé en juin 2003, Issa's Mars
Express a atteint Mars en moins de sept
mois, il a profité de la planète
passage le plus proche de la Terre depuis 60 000 ans
c'était le premier de l'agence spatiale européenne
mission sur la planète rouge et Rose
Des cendres de la Mars ratée de la Russie
96 missions
L'Europe avait réalisé un progrès technique majeur
contribution à l'enquête russe mais
après un lancement réussi, le quatrième
la scène n'a pas réussi à se rallumer et Mars 96
brûlé dans l'atmosphère terrestre
bien qu'il n'y ait aucune similitude extérieure
entre les sondes que Mars Express contient
bon nombre des mêmes capteurs et
instrumentation comme son russe
prédécesseur
[Musique]
comme la sonde a été en train d'imaginer le
surface martienne
les instruments sont conçus pour découvrir
en savoir plus sur l'atmosphère de la planète et
sa géologie
y compris des traces d'eau de surface qui
a peut-être existé dans le passé
Les images de contour de la surface révèlent
fonctionnalités qui nous sont familières comme
ayant été causé par une éruption volcanique
mais toute activité tectonique a cessé
il y a longtemps
Mars montre également des signes d'érosion, mais le
les canaux sont asséchés depuis longtemps
mais le fait que l'eau coulait ici
Peut signifier que la vie rudimentaire est devenue
commencé
tout comme la Terre, Mars tourne sur un
axe incliné lui donnant des saisons mais
parce que l'orbite de la planète est très
elliptique, il existe une grande variabilité dans
températures de surface
en été, il peut faire 20 degrés
Celsius tombant à moins 90 du jour au lendemain
[Musique]
Mars possède également des calottes glaciaires polaires, mais elles
sont faits de glace d'eau recouverte en hiver
par une couche de CO2 gelé cette superposition
le processus n’est pas entièrement compris
les instruments sur Mars Express suggèrent que
la mince atmosphère est de 95 CO2 avec
traces d'azote, d'oxygène et d'eau
vapeur
les nuages ​​fins et les vents forts du port
désormais les seules forces capables d'influencer le
la topographie de la surface sont des tempêtes de poussière et
impacts de météores
[Musique]
Mars Express est une orbite elliptique
autour de Mars perpendiculairement à l'orbite
de Phobos, la Lune majeure de Mars
récemment, il s'est rapproché le plus de
la Petite Lune qui est trop petite pour avoir
une forme sphérique
[Musique]
Phobos a l'apparence d'un capturé
astéroïde mais les scientifiques sont intrigués par
sa masse et sa densité sont inférieures à
attendu donc on pense qu'il est poreux
[Musique]
depuis qu'il est en orbite, l'infrarouge
le spectromètre sur Mars Express a
continué à découvrir de l'eau qui a
les chercheurs planétaires améliorent leurs
les attentes qu'une certaine forme de vie puisse
ont existé autrefois sur Mars
Mars Express a eu plusieurs missions
extensions de nouvelles mesures ont été
institué pour conserver le vaisseau spatial
les réserves de carburant diminuent et il semble
comme si la mission se poursuivrait jusqu'à son
le carburant s'épuise enfin
[Musique]
merci
L'emblématique lanceur russe Sawyers au
cosmodrome de Baïkonour
merci
actuellement c'est le seul moyen de prendre
cosmonautes vers l'espace international
Gare
ce qui le rend spécial, c'est son direct
lignée avec les conceptions historiques qui
a lancé le premier satellite et le
premier homme dans l'espace
la similitude extérieure la plus frappante est
les quatre boosters à sangle
ensemble, ils constituent la première étape
le noyau central autour duquel ils
le cluster est connu comme la deuxième étape
même si c'est des nuits avant le lancement
avec les strapons
ces étages sont alimentés au kérosène avec
un oxydant d'oxygène liquide
après 118 secondes les quatre premières étapes
les boosters sont largués et le second
la scène continuera à brûler pendant un autre
trois minutes
comme les autres Rockets russes, les Sawyers
tire son nom de l'un de ses plus
charges utiles fréquemment soulevées, le Sawyer
vaisseau spatial qui a été en service
depuis 1967.
[Musique]
depuis le retrait de l'espace américain
La navette spatiale Sawyer a joué
un rôle indispensable dans le transport des équipages
vers et depuis l'espace international
Gare
d'une capacité de trois cosmonautes et
l'ISS ayant une équipe de travail de
six, il doit y avoir deux Soyouz
vaisseau spatial à portée de main à la station spatiale
au cas où une évacuation serait nécessaire
[Musique]
le système de lancement du Sawyer utilise très
techniques de production simples contrairement aux
Navette américaine et Saturn Vibes
le soyouz est assemblé horizontalement
ce qui permet d'économiser énormément d'argent supplémentaire
matériel de fabrication et complexité
l'intégration du vinyle se fait sur un wagon
et intègre le bras de levage qui
soulèvera la fusée sur la rampe de lancement
le voyage vers le pad se fait en marchant
rythme et c'est une tradition russe qui
les cosmonautes qui doivent voler seront témoins du
dérouler
au niveau du pad, l'hydraulique est utilisée pour soulever
les sols à la verticale là où il se trouve
suspendu au-dessus du foyer et
soutenu par quatre bras à contrepoids
des portiques de ravitaillement et de service également
entourer la fusée
les portiques seront retirés avant
lancement laissant l'unique en forme de tulipe
configuration
cela a été initialement conçu pour ajouter un supplément
soutien à la fusée en attente alors que le
Le site de lancement de Baïkono est connu pour son
vents forts
en 2011, un lanceur Sawyer était en cours
préparé pour le lancement
à partir de celui-ci a été adapté pour une utilisation au
Port spatial européen en Guyane française
avec une capacité de levage améliorée et un
commercial record de lancement enviable
les clients satellite adorent les Sawyer
[Musique]
d'accord
tu penses
[Musique]
belle vallée vraiment incroyable
la Station spatiale internationale a été
occupe depuis l'an 2000 sa primaire
le rôle est la science
le simple fait de le faire fonctionner est un
tâche immense
c'est Freedom Seven, le carburant est Go 1.2
Cabine G à 14 PSI en mai 1961 Alan
Shepard avait effectué un bref vol sous-orbital
hop dans sa liberté 7 Space Capsule le
Booster Redstone qui avait été lancé
Shepherd n'était pas capable de soulever un
vaisseau spatial lourd en orbite
le vol a provoqué une célébration en Amérique
mais en comparaison, le premier homme dans l'espace
Le Russe Youri Gagarine avait réalisé un
orbite terrestre complète et il serait devenu un
Célébrité internationale
la nouvelle agence spatiale américaine
La NASA avait été chargée de fermer le
écart de technologie spatiale avec ses communistes
adversaire l'Union soviétique et le projet
Mercure était le moyen pour y parvenir
jusqu'au booster Atlas plus puissant
était prêt tôt
Le projet que Mercury avait était le Redstone et
La NASA était désireuse de perfectionner le Mercury
capsule donc un deuxième vol sub-orbital
était prévue
l'astronaute serait Gus Grissom
les réalisations spectaculaires dans l'espace qui
survenu ces dernières semaines
aurait dû nous faire comprendre à tous moins
plus de trois semaines après le vol de Shepard
Le président américain a eu un rôle décisif
contribution
dans l'esprit des hommes du monde entier
qui tentent de faire un
détermination de la route à suivre
prendre
Je crois que cette nation devrait s'engager
lui-même pour atteindre l'objectif avant cela
La décennie est finie. Atterrir un homme sur le
lune et le ramène sain et sauf à la
Terre
à la NASA, le programme de formation et le
préparation pour le deuxième Mercure
vol avec l'astronaute Gus Grissom
s'est poursuivi comme prévu, mais
les administrateurs ont réalisé que leur
l'annonce du président signifierait un
expansion rapide de l'agence spatiale
du nouveau personnel a été embauché et à long terme
des contrats ont été négociés immédiatement
importance ou des modifications à
Capsule de mercure
à la demande des astronautes, une fenêtre est
ajouté et une nouvelle trappe utilisant un explosif
les boulons ont été conçus pour être plus rapides
sortie
70 boulons maintenaient la trappe en place mais
ceux-ci avaient maintenant un point faible intentionnel
et une petite charge explosive exploserait
hors de la trappe si nécessaire
Gus Grissom serait le premier à voler
avec la nouvelle trappe
déclenché à la fois de l’intérieur et de l’extérieur
la capsule
le matin du 21 juillet 1961
une autre fusée Redstone était alimentée
depuis le vol orbital de Youri Gagarine en
Avril, rien n'avait été entendu du
Les Russes et l'équipe Mercury pouvaient ressentir
ils pourraient être en train de rattraper leur retard
adversaires communistes
[Musique]
la météo avait déjà provoqué ce vol
être reporté trois fois
Grissom avait nommé sa capsule Mercure
Liberty Bell sept, tout est confus
Le vaisseau spatial Mercury portait le numéro sept
parce qu'il y avait sept astronautes
cette mission était similaire à celle d'Alan
Le vol de Shepard d'une durée d'environ 15
minutes avec les événements les plus importants
se produit automatiquement, mais le
Le système de contrôle du propulseur avait été
modifié mais Grissom aurait moins
que trois minutes pour le tester
la tour de lancement a reculé après un
retard d'une demi-heure sur l'un des boulons de la trappe
était mal aligné et il a fallu aux ingénieurs
un certain temps pour conclure que le reste
69 boulons suffiraient
zéro
[Musique]
Roger
Roger sur l'horloge fonctionne
tester la commande manuelle du propulseur
Grissom l'a trouvé plus lent que le
simulateur au sol lors du passage à
le nouveau système de contrôle-commande de taux qu'il
j'ai trouvé que ça fonctionnait bien, c'était lourd
carburant
Je peux vraiment voir les nuages
trop vite, il se préparait
rentrée sur ce qui semblait parfait
vol
l'avion dans la zone d'atterrissage a repéré un
Balise radio qui a démarré lorsque le
capsules parachutes déployées
les hélicoptères ont rapidement retrouvé Liberty Bell 7
flottant droit sur la cible, tout
semblait normal à l’intérieur de la capsule
Grissom avait déverrouillé le dispositif de sécurité
la trappe
peu de temps après que la charge explosive ait explosé
l'écoutille s'est ouverte et l'engin a commencé
remplir d'eau
Grissom a dû sauter à l'écart et le
l'hélicoptère avait du mal à soulever le
capsule remplie d'eau à l'abri des vagues
les voyants d'avertissement dans le hachoir indiquent
le moteur avait été surchargé et que
l'échec était imminent, le pilote a largué
la capsule qui a coulé sous cinq
mille mètres de l'Atlantique
Grissom avait eu du mal à rester
à flot aussi et il a été treuillé pour se mettre en sécurité
dans une combinaison spatiale remplie d'eau
la perte de la capsule sur son précieux
les données n'étaient pas bonnes et immédiatement
Les ingénieurs ont commencé à se demander comment la trappe
pourrait exploser tout seul
Grissom était catégorique sur le fait que l'écoutille
soufflé tout seul
alors qu'il était encore trempé de
les médecins essayaient de l'examiner, il a pris un
appel de félicitations du président
Kennedy
[Musique]
Le vol suborbital de Gus Grissom
être la dernière mission Mercury à utiliser le
booster Redstone sous-alimenté
Les planificateurs du projet Mercury voulaient que leur
prochain astronaute à entrer en orbite mais
il y a eu un problème le plus puissant
Booster Atlas sur lequel ils comptaient uniquement
avait un taux de réussite de 30
conçu en 1955, l'atlas a été développé
comme système de lancement d'armes nucléaires, mais
en 1961, la technologie n'était pas encore arrivée à maturité
ce n'était pas fiable
à ce stade, la NASA avait lancé trois
combinaisons sans pilote Mercury Atlas et
deux avaient échoué de façon catastrophique
[Musique]
La NASA commençait à se disputer avec Convair
les Rockets Builders sur la fiabilité
modifications incluant une peau plus épaisse
et un système de télémétrie transistorisé
ont été présenté
[Musique]
mais ensuite l'Union soviétique a lancé
Vostok 2.
les gros titres des journaux racontent l'histoire
Herman Titoff de Russie revient sur terre
après avoir fait 17 fois le tour du globe en un
un peu plus de 25 heures couvrant 435
000 miles, soit plus du double de
distance de la Terre à la Lune et
une orbite par un astronaute américain est prévue
Plus tard cette année
[Musique]
il s'appelait Enos et juste un chimpanzé
Ham avait testé le premier Mercure
Redstone Enos testerait le Mercury
Atlas
La NASA a tout donné, c'est vraiment dangereux
missions auprès des chimpanzés
en novembre 1961, Enos décolle
[Musique]
il a fait deux orbites en trois heures et 20
minutes et même si ce n'était pas un
Mission sans faille qu'il a donnée aux planificateurs
confiance que la plupart des problèmes avaient
été éliminé de l'Atlas de Mercure
combinaison
la prochaine mission Mercury transporterait
John Glenn
il serait le premier homme américain à orbiter
la planète
la lumière était prévue pour janvier le
16 1962 mais problèmes techniques et puis
les problèmes liés à la météo ont fait que le
le lancement avait été retardé jusqu'en février
le 20
pour les États-Unis, c'était un événement important
Mission, cela montrerait qu'ils étaient
rattraper les Russes qui avaient
ont clairement démontré leur capacité
pour les vols orbitaux de longue durée
[Musique]
les gens étaient rassemblés le long des plages
de la Floride centrale pour assister au lancement
et la fierté nationale était en jeu
merci
la guerre froide avait renforcé les étoiles et
Le patriotisme des rayures et John Glenn dans le
vaisseau spatial qu'il avait nommé amitié sept
portait un grand coup pour la vérité, la justice
et à la manière américaine
John Glenn
Hé
[Musique]
Mark opère, nous sommes en route
tout dans le lancement était proche de
impeccable
cinq minutes et demie après blastoth
Friendship Seven était en orbite et
Mission Control a confirmé la trajectoire
était bon pendant au moins sept orbites
[Applaudissements]
il y a eu un problème mineur avec les propulseurs
mais lorsqu'un capteur défectueux a indiqué que
le bouclier thermique du vaisseau spatial était venu
lâche, il a été décidé d'amener le
mission terminée après seulement trois
orbites
je me retournais toujours et je pouvais voir le
booster pendant le retournement d'un couple
trois jours après son retour à un
cérémonie au Centre du vaisseau spatial Mann
le président a décoré John Glenn avec
Le prix du service distingué de la NASA et
Soutien américain au programme d’espace à la demande
était enthousiaste
[Musique]
il y avait trois autres orbitales habitées
vols du programme Mercury
chacun augmentant la durée du raffinage
technique et technologie
finalement le dernier Mercure programmé
les missions ont été annulées au profit du
prochain programme
La NASA était dans une course vers la Lune et
Le projet Gemini a été une grande étape qui
direction
[Musique]
depuis le début des lancements de fusées
Les ingénieurs ont utilisé une série de caméras
pour surveiller le comportement de leur vaisseau et comme
La technologie des fusées s'est développée, tout comme
les caméras
un lancement de navette typique a été surveillé
par 135 caméras différentes
caméras fixes filmant à 400 images par
deuxièmement, capturer à la fois le combustible solide
les propulseurs et les moteurs-fusées afin que
toute anomalie peut être scrutée
détail après le lancement
d'autres unités entourent la zone du pad pour
enregistrer le lancement de tous les
angle
dans la période précédant le décollage lorsque
l'accès au complexe de lancement est limité
les caméras jouent un rôle essentiel dans
inspections pré-vol continues
un autre groupe appelé The Final
L'équipe d'inspection est équipée de
caméras portables, ils ont un accès étroit
au pad et lancez Gantry n'importe quoi
hors de l'ordinaire est enregistré pour
un examen plus approfondi par une équipe de
spécialistes au centre de lancement
merci en plus le lancement
l'équipe de direction peut demander des images de
tout sous-système qui pourrait revenir
lectures suspectes
l'équipe peut identifier et photographier
des problèmes qui autrement pourraient passer inaperçus
[Musique]
lorsqu'un vaisseau spatial quitte le sol
différent ensemble de caméras de suivi
continuer à enregistrer il y a 17 supports
des trackers de distance près du périmètre du
Zone de lancement et au moins 21 à longue portée
traqueurs
[Musique]
exécuter à la fois la vidéo haute définition et 35
film millimétrique, ils sont essentiellement
contrôlé par radar avec réglage fin
via un joystick si sensible qu'il peut choisir
faire battre le cœur de l'opérateur
le 16 janvier 2003, l'espace
la navette Columbia a décollé dans un
ciel bleu clair 83 secondes après le décollage
un morceau de mousse isolante s'est détaché
du réservoir externe frappant le
l'aile gauche de la navette, il a été récupéré par
deux des caméras de suivi
bien que la mousse soit très légère,
L'incident s'est produit alors que la Colombie était
voyageant à environ 800 kilomètres par
heure
[Musique]
l'équipage de sept personnes a été perdu lorsque Columbia
rompu lors de la rentrée deux semaines plus tard
une enquête a révélé que de la mousse
des grèves avaient été observées avant
la normalisation de la déviance était
responsable de ne pas avoir réparé le
problème plus tôt
les vols de la navette ont été cloués au sol et les images
des caméras de suivi ont conduit à un
refonte des réservoirs externes
isolation
les vols de navette, à une exception près, étaient
limité à l'espace international
Gare à l'arrivée, chaque navette était
nécessaire pour effectuer un retournement progressif
permettant aux caméras de l'ISS de capturer
images des tuiles thermiques du Craft
[Musique]
merci, tout dommage révélé signifierait
les astronautes pourraient attendre à la station
un retour sur Terre lors d'un vol ultérieur
mais de telles précautions ne faisaient que révéler le
vulnérabilités de la navette Aging et
la flotte a été retirée en 2011, laissant
les États-Unis sans évaluation humaine
vaisseau spatial
[Musique]
dans un domaine qui s'appuie sur l'avant-garde
technologie les navettes vieilles de 30 ans
ne pouvait plus être mis à jour mais un nouveau
Le système est en route, l'Orion avec
chaque étape de test et de développement
étant méticuleusement enregistré
[Musique]
la Station spatiale internationale dessert
comme plateforme de recherche et d'observation
dans l'environnement en apesanteur des basses
orbite terrestre
il est continuellement occupé depuis
L'équipage de l'expédition 1 a élu domicile à
l'année 2000.
l'ISS a une masse de 450 000 kilogrammes
ce qui en fait facilement le plus grand
objet en orbite
la station spatiale a ses origines dans le
Russe simple II, il était conçu comme un
remplacement du simple espace vieillissant
station qui était en orbite depuis
1986.
lancé par l'Union soviétique le
le miroir d'origine était très détérioré
vers la fin de sa vie de 15 ans
le premier de la Station spatiale internationale
le composant était le module zarya
initialement prévu comme première pièce
de Mir II
les États-Unis avaient une proposition pour une station spatiale
la liberté et l'Agence spatiale européenne
planifions la station spatiale Columbus
mais le coût prohibitif d'un tel
Les entreprises ont conduit à une consolidation du
différents schémas la navette spatiale
est devenu vital dans la mise en orbite
projet de construction
étranger
le deuxième composant était américain
en tant que module Unity, il a été ajouté
1998.
pendant 13 ans, la station spatiale a pris
façonner le proton russe et celui de Sawyer
Les fusées ainsi que la navette
livraison de composants
le dernier vol de navette jamais réalisé en 2011 a eu lieu
mettre en place un système européen polyvalent
module logistique
à ce moment-là, il s'agissait de 15
segments pressurisés et une ferme
assemblage qui ancre les panneaux solaires
et les radiateurs de refroidissement quand même le
L'ISS reste inachevée avec à la fois un
Un bras robotique européen et un russe
laboratoire polyvalent encore à construire
livré
[Musique]
les modules russes pourraient tous s'amarrer
automatiquement mais une quantité considérable
des travaux de construction ont été réalisés par
astronautes basés dans la station
même après la fin des travaux
entretien régulier et réparations en cours
exiger que les spécialistes de mission aillent
dehors
étranger
les fonctionnalités à ajouter étaient le coupleur
qui comprend la Station spatiale
la plus grande fenêtre
les vues sont époustouflantes
le son lorsque l'ISS se déplace au-dessus des pôles
régions du nord et du sud
les aurores apparaissent sous forme de bandes irisées dans le
haute atmosphère
c'est une indication d'une énergie solaire élevée
activité avec la douche solaire
la Terre en particules chargées
généralement, car l'ISS est dans une zone terrestre basse
l'activité solaire en orbite ne présente pas de
danger pour la santé de l'équipage de la station spatiale
car ils sont protégés par la Terre
champ magnétique qui dévie tout sauf
les éjections les plus intenses du Soleil
[Musique]
cependant, lorsque des éruptions solaires sont détectées
l'équipage doit s'abriter en Russie
segment orbital qui a été protégé contre
protéger contre l’augmentation des radiations
quand même, les membres de l'équipage de l'ISS en une journée
recevoir autant de rayonnements qu'une personne
La Terre aura dans un an
[Musique]
étranger
Les nations lanceront un navire de ravitaillement pour
l'ISS
depuis 2009, l'agence aérospatiale japonaise jaxa
a envoyé quatre cargos à tige blanche
Issa a envoyé cinq virements automatiques
Véhicules qui accostent automatiquement et
rester à la gare pendant environ six heures
mois
depuis le retrait de l'Espace
Navette utilisée par les États-Unis
entrepreneurs commerciaux pour le réapprovisionnement
comme le Dragon du navire japonais SpaceX
un cargo viendra à côté et attendra
être capturé par le robot de la station
bras
le visiteur le plus fréquent est le Russe
Cheval de trait que les Sawyers utilisaient pour Ferry et
membres d'équipage et son équivalent cargo
progrès
ceux-ci s'amarrent également automatiquement
[Musique]
Les vaisseaux de Sawyer restent à l'ISS pendant
évacuation d'urgence
avec l'arrivée d'un nouveau cargo
l'équipage de l'ISS est occupé à décharger et
ranger de nouvelles provisions
finalement la capsule cargo est remplie
avec des déchets et largué
une exposition à long terme à la microgravité conduit
à la perte de masse musculaire et de densité osseuse
et l'exercice quotidien est important dans
réduire les conséquences sur la santé
apesanteur
en dehors des tâches courantes en gardant le
station spatiale fonctionnant les astronautes
le travail régulier est une science
cela peut aller de la surveillance
des spécimens végétaux et animaux simples étant
élevé en microgravité à la recherche de
Matière noire via l'alpha magnétique
spectromètre
à la fin de leur séjour de six mois
l'ISS trois cosmonautes s'entassent
dans la capsule Soyouz en attente et
préparer le voyage de retour sur Terre
[Musique]
trois heures et demie après le métier
désamarre, les cosmonautes seront sur le
terrain au Kazakhstan
[Musique]
les principaux partenaires que l'Amérique et la Russie ne peuvent pas
convenir du financement pour la poursuite
opérations au-delà de 2020, ce qui pourrait signifier
la fin du Laboratoire en orbite
étranger
[Musique]
vraiment incroyable
conçu en 1974 et toujours aussi performant
l'Emu est la combinaison spatiale qui
les astronautes continuent d'utiliser sur le
Station spatiale internationale
merci
Les Gémeaux ont été l'intérim bref mais intense
programme où la NASA a lancé Rendezvous
Manœuvres nécessaires pour les missions lunaires
en 1963, le projet Mercury était allé aussi loin
car la technologie permettrait le résultat final
trois missions ont été annulées afin que
La NASA pourrait se concentrer sur un nouveau programme
et développer les techniques nécessaires pour
atteindre la lune
il a été décidé qu'avant de se lancer
le programme Apollo à trois a eu
été conçu comme une étape intermédiaire pour
en savoir plus sur Rendez-vous orbital et
un amarrage était nécessaire, c'était à Houston
que M. Kennedy a souligné la nécessité
utilisations pacifiques, il s'appelait Projet
Les Gémeaux et à bien des égards le nouveau
la capsule du programme était plus avancée que
le vaisseau spatial Apollo qui suivrait
il a été conçu pour un équipage de deux hommes
et les astronautes l'appelaient le Gus
mobile parce que le vétéran de Mercury, Gus
Grissom avait joué un rôle majeur dans son
développement
le vaisseau spatial Gemini aurait le
capacité à changer d'orbite et il
instrumentation et systèmes inclus
qui ont été empruntés aux chasseurs à réaction
l'une de ses fonctionnalités les plus révolutionnaires
C'était son ordinateur de bord, il avait une mémoire
de seulement 20 kilo-octets
au début, il a été proposé que
la capsule Gemini n'aurait pas d'atterrissage
des parachutes mais une aile regalo
Grissom a participé aux premiers tests
avant que cette idée ne soit abandonnée, elle a ajouté
une couche de complexité qui ne pourrait pas être
facilement logé dans la capsule
conception et la NASA est revenue à la
amerrissage traditionnel
[Musique]
pour propulser le vaisseau spatial Gemini en orbite
La NASA a adapté à la hâte les
Missile Titan II
le Titan 2 avait un design beaucoup plus simple
parce qu'il utilisait un propulseur hypergolique
qui pourrait rester stocké dans la fusée
pendant de longues périodes
les deux composants du carburant n'étaient pas nécessaires
être conservé à des températures inférieures à zéro, mais
ils étaient extrêmement toxiques et dangereux
gérer
les concepteurs ont compris que tout lancement
un accident ne causerait pas le grand
explosion vue avec de l'oxygène liquide donc
ils ont renoncé au lancement Escape
système utilisé dans le programme Mercury et
équipe la capsule Gemini d'un éjecteur
des places
des astronautes originaux de Mercury 7
seuls Grissom Shira et Cooper sont restés
le reste ayant quitté la NASA ou ayant
été suspendu pour raisons médicales
pour renforcer son noyau de pilotes spatiaux NASA
a accueilli un deuxième groupe de neuf
astronautes en 1962 et 14 autres le
l'année suivante
[Musique]
avant que les astronautes puissent piloter le
La combinaison Gemini Titan devait être
testé pour démontrer sa fiabilité
le booster était sujet à Rapid
variations de poussée connues sous le nom de Pogo
oscillations
des modifications ont été apportées à la fusée
et vols sans pilote de Gemini 1 et 2
ont été réalisés en 1964 et 1965.
Gus Grissom, vétéran de Mercury, et nouveau
la recrue John Young volerait en premier
mission Gemini habitée
parce que le vaisseau Gemini était équipé de
sièges éjectables, ils ont eu une formation spéciale
exercices qui impliquaient de sauter en parachute dans
l'eau
les deux astronautes ont également passé de longues heures
dans le simulateur Gemini où les ingénieurs
pourrait les faire traverser des défis
scénarios qui peuvent se produire dans l'espace alors
forme également des contrôleurs de mission
le vol Gemini 3 était prévu pour
le 23 mars 1965 et comme lancement
date approchée, la publicité est devenue intense
le nouveau président Lyndon Johnson était
Hâte d'être vu avec les prochains astronautes
L'Amérique gagnait en confiance dans son
l'avenir dans l'espace
[Musique]
cinq jours avant la date prévue de Gemini 3
décollage de l'Union Soviétique a lancé un
vaisseau spatial biplace ce que personne n'était
je m'attendais à un autre record mondial
première sortie dans l'espace
[Musique]
le cosmonaute Alexi Leonov a quitté son Dieu Vos
2 capsules pour flotter librement dans l'espace pendant
12 minutes
en Occident, il était perçu comme un autre
Triomphe soviétique
[Musique]
en réalité, le costume de Leonard avait été déformé
et il a juste pu revenir
à l'intérieur, toute la mission était en proie
avec des difficultés mais ces détails
n'a pas été révélé depuis des décennies
[Musique]
étranger pour l'Amérique, Gemini 3 ressemblait à un
bon retour dans l'espace comme c'était le cas
presque deux ans depuis la NASA
l'astronaute avait été ignoré
tu es en route Molly Brown, ce serait
soyez le premier des 10 Gémeaux habités
missions que les médias américains faisaient
noms familiers des astronautes
réalisations du nouveau maniable
l'espace de fabrication incluait le premier changement
en forme orbitale et le premier changement de
plan orbital
après seulement trois orbites Grissom et Yan
revenu sur Terre
pendant les astronautes du programme Mercury
avaient nommé leurs capsules
Grissom avait nommé Gemini 3 Molly Brown
après le spectacle de Broadway L'Insubmersible
Molly Brown Nessa n'a pas aimé ça car
c'était une référence au Mercure de Grissom
capsule qui avait coulé au fond de
l'océan
à peine trois jours après leur retour à
Earth Grissom et Yang étaient au Blanc
Maison où le président Johnson a présenté
eux avec le service distingué de la NASA
médaille
[Musique]
étranger
alors quelque chose qui allait devenir courant
à travers les missions Gemini, un téléscripteur
défilé dans les rues de New York
La NASA a compris que le public américain
j'avais besoin de quelque chose en retour mais le
programme spatial extrêmement coûteux qu'il a donné
eux une nouvelle marque de héros
la prochaine mission Gemini 4 serait un
vol d'une durée beaucoup plus longue et son équipage
proviendrait du deuxième apport de la NASA
les astronautes Ed White et Jim Mcdivitt
ils étaient en formation depuis trois
années
White s'était entraîné avec un
unité de manœuvre qu'il utiliserait
lors de la première sortie dans l'espace de la NASA
[Musique]
trois deux un
Gemini 4 a décollé le 3 juin
1965.
après que le vol précédent ait vérifié
le vaisseau spatial ceci
je trouverais comment l'utiliser
peu de temps après avoir atteint l'orbite, l'équipage
situé les Rockets écartés en deuxième position
scène et j'ai essayé de m'y rapprocher en utilisant
des repères visuels uniquement, mais plus il y a de mac divot
manœuvré vers lui plus loin
le booster a eu Rendez-vous allait
être plus difficile qu'il n'y paraît et Mission
Le contrôle a annulé l'exercice
il y avait une tâche plus importante
pendant la troisième orbite, Ed White a ouvert
la porte de la capsule dépressurisée
et en utilisant l'unité de manœuvre surnommée
pistolet zippé, il s'est déplacé dans le vide
cet exercice avait été déplacé vers le haut
Calendrier des Gémeaux après le succès de
Sortie dans l'espace d'Alexi Leonos
bientôt un gant égaré dérivait du
capsule, il continuerait en orbite pendant
encore un mois avant de brûler dans le
l'atmosphère terrestre
la sortie dans l'espace a été réussie, sauf pour
une petite pause dans les communications
les directeurs de vol disent de rentrer
c'est Jim ce que Johnny filme pour nous
Jimmy Ford rentre bien
d'accord
maintenant Roger, nous avons essayé de parler
toi pendant un moment ici une autre première pour
Gemini 4 était que le centre de contrôle avait
a déménagé de Cap Canaveral dans une nouvelle maison
à Houston
et parce que la mission devait durer
quatre jours, c'était la première fois que
trois équipes distinctes de huit heures avaient
mis en service
euh
il y avait eu un problème avec le
l'ordinateur et la trappe avaient été
difficile à ouvrir et à fermer mais comme
Gemini 4 est rentré sur Terre
atmosphère Mission Control a considéré le
vol comme un succès mais ils savaient maintenant
les futures missions devront se concentrer sur
rendez-vous orbital
[Musique]
honneurs d'après-vol pour les blancs et
McDevitt a inclus une cérémonie au
Université du Michigan où ils ont eu
tous deux ont étudié
lors d'une autre cérémonie, le président a épinglé
Les médailles pour services exceptionnels de la NASA
eux
étranger
[Musique]
commençait tout juste à tenir ses promesses mais l'Amérique
je n'étais toujours pas sûr qu'ils attrapaient
avec l'Union Soviétique
Vénus fait un peu plus de 43 millions de kilomètres
les premiers astronomes croyaient que c'était
semblable à la Terre
en 2005, Issa a lancé le Venus Express
Mission et après huit ans de proximité
observation dont nous en savons maintenant beaucoup plus
le plus proche voisin de notre planète
[Musique]
les températures à la surface de Vénus sont plus élevées
que 450 degrés Celsius et son
la pression atmosphérique est presque 100 fois supérieure
plus grand qu'ici sur Terre
[Musique]
tu as des nuages ​​composés de
l'acide sulfurique en fait donc c'est un très
endroit désagréable où être et c'est l'un des
les grandes questions sur Vénus, pourquoi
Vénus est allée par là et pourquoi avons-nous
la terre va par là, la planète prend 243
Les jours terrestres tournent sur son propre axe et
seulement 220 jours pour faire le tour du Soleil
[Musique]
et sa rotation est opposée à celle de la Terre
avec le soleil se levant dans l'ouest de Venise
vents violents dans la haute atmosphère de Venise
souffler à des vitesses allant jusqu'à 400 kilomètres par
heure et il y a des ouragans permanents
près de 200 kilomètres en mouvement
autour de son pôle
des informations sur le climat et
le champ magnétique a été collecté par
Vénus express depuis sa mise en orbite
autour de Vénus en 2006, il a été réalisé
accessible à un large éventail de
experts
comme Vénus l'a exprimé vers la fin de son
la vie opérationnelle de ses gestionnaires a commencé
prendre des risques en guidant la sonde plus près
et plus près de la planète où il pourrait
observer plus en détail
dans une manœuvre connue sous le nom d'Aero brisant le
sonde a traversé la partie supérieure de Vénus
atmosphère
nous nous rapprochons si près qu'en fait nous
ressenti l'atmosphère comme une friction
contre la structure du vaisseau spatial
et de cette façon nous pouvons mesurer les densités
dans cette dans l'atmosphère de
Vénus que nous n'avons pas pu
mesurer pour perdre huit ans que nous sommes
faire le tour de la planète
nous mesurons également les champs magnétiques
avec le magnétomètre et on mesure
particules énergétiques que l'on y retrouve
c'est donc un tout nouveau type de mesures
et des données très précieuses que nous collectons
ces jours
au final, Venus Express a dépassé son
dossier de conception pour collecter une nouvelle classe de
informations sur Vénus
[Musique]
cela nous aide à comprendre le
évolution de notre système solaire et avec
Vénus étant très proche de la taille de
Les sciences de la Terre gagnent un aperçu de
L'avenir possible de la Terre
[Musique]
depuis les premiers jours des vols vers
espace, chaque nouveau vaisseau spatial avait un nouveau
combinaison spatiale conçue spécialement pour accompagner
il
le programme Mercury utilisait une version de
le Mark IV de l'US Navy
les astronautes Gemini portaient le g3c et
g5c qui étaient basés sur le costume porté par
Pilotes X-15
ils ont dû faire face à une éventuelle éjection
et avec des sorties dans l'espace
les astronautes d'Apollo portaient des versions de
la combinaison spatiale a7l, elle devait pouvoir
faire face à l'environnement lunaire et
protéger son porteur pendant combien de fois
ça avait l'air dur de s'allonger
[Applaudissements]
avec le développement de l'Espace
La navette est arrivée avec deux nouvelles combinaisons spatiales, les as
ou des costumes de citrouille portés par l'équipage pendant
lancement et atterrissage
et pour travailler dehors dans le vide de
espacer l'Emu pour des véhicules supplémentaires
Unité de mobilité
[Musique]
l'Emu est comme un mini vaisseau spatial
fournit un support de vie autonome pour
son porteur pendant plus de huit heures et
c'était un costume dans lequel les astronautes
appris en techniques de construction spatiale
pendant les premières années de navette
la conception a été commandée par la NASA en
1974.
et même s'il y en a eu beaucoup
raffinements essentiellement le même émeu est
toujours en service sur l'International
Station spatiale
c'est l'émeu qui a permis au
construction du Laboratoire en orbite
[Musique]
la combinaison comporte 14 couches différentes avec un
gamme de fonctions différentes, y compris
isolation contre les températures extrêmes
et protection contre les micrométéoroïdes
[Musique]
la pression à l'intérieur de la combinaison est d'environ un
quart de la pression atmosphérique standard
cela signifie moins de mobilité mais le faible
pression signifie que l'astronaute doit
respirer des bulles d'oxygène et d'azote pur
se condenserait dans celui du porteur
circulation sanguine et tissus corporels si faibles
de l'air sous pression a été utilisé
en préparation d'une sortie dans l'espace et
l'astronaute doit pré-respirer de l'oxygène pur
pendant plusieurs heures pour purger son système de
l'azote et ce processus commence avant
l'astronaute commence à monter dans son
costume
la partie supérieure de la combinaison est rigide
coque en fibre de verre qu'elle offre
fixation ferme pour le système de survie
sac à dos et trousse à outils montés au
poitrine
[Musique]
dans le cadre de leur préparation à un
séjour dans l'Espace International
Les spécialistes de mission de station dépenseront
de longues heures de formation dans l'émeu au
laboratoire de flottabilité neutre à Houston
les membres de l'équipage doivent être préparés à
tâches de maintenance inattendues en dehors du
SSI
problèmes avec les boucles de liquide de refroidissement des panneaux solaires
et la plomberie qui fuit a nécessité une réparation
sorties dans l'espace
le costume russe ou terrestre est également utilisé sur
l'ISS
il offre un peu moins de mobilité que
l'Emu mais il est beaucoup plus rapide à enfiler
et sa maintenance en orbite est beaucoup
plus simple
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vraiment
[Musique]
l'Emu a été conçu pour être entretenu sur
au sol mais les équipages de l'ISS ont dû
s'adapter et apprendre à ouvrir la combinaison
pour localiser les problèmes et les résoudre
pour les réparations complexes Spécialistes du sol
ont même préparé des instructions vidéo
pour que l'équipage de l'ISS suive
problème complet à chaque fois que la combinaison est
mis, on vérifie l'étanchéité pendant que
de petites pertes sont attendues tout
une fuite importante doit être réparée
immédiatement
Michael, astronaute de la navette et médecin
Barrett a dû localiser et remplacer un
joint torique endommagé, la défaillance d'un tel
une petite partie pourrait menacer le tout
mission
une nouvelle combinaison spatiale de la série Z est en cours
développés mais les évaluations ne seront pas
terminer au moins jusqu'en 2020 afin que le
l'émeu familier restera en service pendant
encore un moment
le costume vintage des années 1970 qui a construit le
ISS et conservé le télescope spatial Hubble
le travail mérite sa grande réputation
lorsqu'une sonde ou un satellite est lancé, il
ne peut remplir sa fonction qu'en raison de
une infrastructure de communication complexe
ici sur Terre
un engin opérant dans l'espace lointain envoie
données via un émetteur avec signal
résistance similaire à celle d'une lampe domestique
ampoule au moment où elle atteint la Terre un
distance mesurée en millions de
kilomètres, ce signal est incroyablement
faible
ASA, l'agence spatiale européenne, compte trois
des plats géants à des endroits autour du
monde pour qu'il puisse communiquer avec son
réseau de sondes spatiales lointaines
sabreros est situé dans une zone rurale
à l'ouest de la capitale espagnole Madrid où
les interférences électromagnétiques sont à un
minimum, la parabole de 35 mètres est capable de
précision de pointage fine
non seulement le plat doit pointer
directement à sa sonde cible distante, il
doit suivre avec lui pour compenser
à la fois le mouvement de la sonde et le
La rotation de la Terre
Le plat de 620 tonnes doit se déplacer en douceur et
avec une précision inférieure à un kilomètre
à une distance de cent millions
kilomètres
les antennes paraboliques de l'espace lointain doivent transmettre comme
ainsi que recevoir pour cela le pouvoir de
l'émetteur est un signal important
une puissance de 20 000 watts est concentrée dans
un faisceau étroit près de la parabole
la première antenne dans l'espace lointain de l'esa
le réseau s'est construit à une nouvelle nausée en
Sud-ouest de l'Australie
sa conception est similaire à celle des sabreros
station qui capte les signaux de
sondes à mesure que la rotation de la Terre prend
les hors de la vue de la nouvelle nausée
actuellement, le réseau de l'espace lointain dispose d'un
charge de travail lourde comme la sonde Rosetta
continue de transmettre ses propres données et
relayer les informations du Philai Lander
le dernier membre de l'espace profond de l'ESA
Trio est malade en Argentine 1200
kilomètres à l'ouest de Buenos Aires
c'est l'antenne la plus récente du système
ayant été terminé il y a moins de deux ans
il y a
il complète la couverture du Réseau
le ciel dans n'importe quelle direction à tout moment
les trois plats de l'espace profond sont
coordonné depuis l'esoc l'espace européen
centre d'opérations à Darmstadt Allemagne
en plus des sondes spatiales lointaines
L'esoc est également responsable de
communication avec la Terre en orbite
satellites via un groupe différent de
surveillance de petites stations au sol
vaisseau spatial en orbite polaire
depuis plus de 45 ans, le centre
fourni le lien entre la Terre et un
variété de vaisseaux spatiaux de recherche actuellement
le réseau contrôle 13 différents
missions à long terme
[Musique]
Hmm
étranger
je viens juste de l'amener à la surface de Mars
C'était déjà assez difficile mais la Curiosité
Rover continue de changer notre
compréhension de la planète rouge
ok, je sors, ok
dès la sortie des Gémeaux, c'était la NASA à la hâte
programme de transition conçu pour
techniques parfaites nécessaires pour un lunaire
Atterrissage
Gemini 4 a vu l'astronaute Ed White partir
sa capsule et marcher dans l'espace mais le
tentative du vaisseau spatial de rendez-vous avec
son booster avait été un échec
d'accord
Gemini 5 avait établi une endurance américaine
record de près de huit jours mais c'est
L'exercice de rendez-vous a également échoué
le matin du 25 octobre 1965
deux fusées attendaient leur lancement à
Cap Canaveral tandis que les astronautes Wally
Shira et Tom Stafford se préparent pour
Décollage sur Gemini 6. un Atlas spécial
Le véhicule agena Target attendait
pavé 14.
parce que Rendezvous et Docking étaient
partie intégrante de sa stratégie d'alunissage
La NASA avait commandé l'amarrage ajina
module
il serait transporté en orbite au sommet d'un
rappel de l'atlas
alors que l'équipage de Gemini 6 était attaché
dans l'atlas, la combinaison agena était
entrer dans les dernières minutes de son
compte à rebours
le plan était que Gemini 6 se rende à Rendez-vous
et accoster avec l'ajina quatre fois dans un
vol qui devait durer deux
jours
Gemini 6 devait être lancé vers
90 minutes après l'agina avec le
les comptes à rebours sont étroitement synchronisés
[Musique]
le véhicule cible a décollé comme prévu
c'était le premier vol d'Égine dans le cadre
du programme Gemini mais l'atlas
le booster avait bien servi pendant la
Le programme Mercury et l'Air Force avaient
a eu du succès avec l'étage supérieur d'Égine
donc aucun problème n'était attendu
Gemini 6 attendait comme véhicule cible
accéléré après un lancement parfait mais
quelques minutes plus tard, à l'étage supérieur
séparé, toute la télémétrie a été perdue et
le radar de poursuite a détecté cinq
pièces
la mission Gemini était désormais inutile et
le lancement a été annulé avec Shira et
Stafford quitte son vaisseau spatial
il y a eu un débat sur ce qu'il fallait faire ensuite
la programmation du programme Gemini avait
été serré avec environ un nouveau lancement
toutes les six semaines
il n'y avait pas de remplaçant, Égine était prête à
lancement avant le prochain vol Gemini 7.
le matin du 4 décembre 1965
les astronautes Jim Lovell et Frank Borman
prenions notre petit-déjeuner avant le lancement de
leur vaisseau spatial Gemini 7 parmi les
les autres dînant avec eux étaient les Gémeaux
6 équipages qui décolleront neuf jours plus tard
merci
[Musique]
Gemini 7 devait être la durée la plus longue
vol encore et pour le confort pendant presque
Pendant 14 jours en orbite, l'équipage portait
nouvelles combinaisons spatiales légères
Les médecins de la NASA s'inquiétaient du
effet d'une exposition prolongée à
l'apesanteur aurait sur les astronautes
en particulier la perte observée de rouge
cellules sanguines
deux un
Gemini 7 a été conçu pour répondre aux besoins médicaux
des questions
il a été lancé comme prévu avant Gemini 6
qui avait été renommé Gemini 6A
il avait fallu plus de 60 jours à la NASA pour
préparez-vous à un nouveau lancement maintenant, les équipages avaient
huit jours avant le lancement de Gemini 6A
et ils sont immédiatement passés à l'action
dès qu'ils ont atteint l'orbite des Gemini
7 membres d'équipage ont fait demi-tour et ont commencé
tracking avec son étage supérieur Gemini 4
j'ai tenté cela mais cela a échoué à cause d'un
connaissance insuffisante de l'orbite
mécanique
[Musique]
le 12 décembre Shira et Stafford
à nouveau prêt pour le lancement
si tout s'est bien passé dans les six heures suivant
décoller, ils seraient en orbite
aux côtés de Gemini 7.
l'équipage du Launchpad avait fait un excellent
travail de lecture du booster en un temps record
et le compte à rebours s'est poursuivi en douceur
[Musique]
mais ensuite les moteurs ont été arrêtés
commencé et après une seconde ils
arrêté
aujourd'hui
le commandant Shira avait la possibilité de
tirant l'anneau en D et éjectant les deux
les de la capsule mais il est resté bien assis
[Applaudissements]
personne ne savait ce qui n'allait pas pour un
deuxième fois, l'équipage de Gemini 6 avait
échec du lancement
un connecteur s'était détaché avant le
le booster avait décollé et le véhicule embarqué
l'ordinateur a tout fermé
cela a été corrigé avec un autre
problème dans une turbopompe
trois jours plus tard, ils étaient prêts à essayer
encore
[Musique]
27 secondes hors de l'heure
le plan de vol prévoyait le
Rendez-vous sur les Gemini 6
quatrième orbite et Shira a fait la première
correction orbitale 94 minutes après le début
vol
Gemini 7 resterait passif avec tous
ajustements orbitaux effectués par Gemini
6.
après trois heures, un peu plus de 400
kilomètres séparés par deux embarcations et
Gemini 7 a été récupéré par Shira et
Stafford sur le radar
après cinq heures, Gemini 7 est apparu comme un
point brillant et peu après les deux
les vaisseaux spatiaux volaient en formation
six et sept seront là
si tu as quelque chose pour nous
ok, trois ans plus tôt, en 1962,
Les Russes avaient lancé trois vostoks et
quatre pour qu'ils puissent passer près de
l'un l'autre et il semblait que
un autre triomphe soviétique
avec le Rendez-vous des Gémeaux 6 et 7
les Américains ont réalisé que les vostoks
avait réalisé deux lancements au bon moment
une réalisation très différente de celle
Précision sur les changements d'orbite qu'ils ont eu
réalisé
pendant plus de quatre heures les deux
les vaisseaux spatiaux volaient parfois côte à côte
se rapprochant jusqu'à 30 centimètres
cela a donné confiance à la NASA dans son
Rendez-vous technique mais il n'y en a pas
été un amarrage comme cela avait été à l'origine
prévu lorsque la cible avait été le
achina
après un peu plus d'une journée en orbite
Gemini 6 est rentré sur Terre
atmosphère et a été repris dans le
océan Atlantique
[Musique]
a continué en orbite pendant deux autres
journées record avec Borman et
Lovell lit des livres pour passer le temps
ils sont revenus sur Terre en décembre
18 et ont été récupérés par le WASP le
même navire qui avait récupéré le Gemini
6 membres d'équipage
c'est à ce moment-là que la NASA a commencé
à croire le programme spatial américain
acquérait une plus grande expertise que leur
Adversaires soviétiques
cependant, l'insaisissable exercice d'amarrage avait
toujours pas eu lieu et personne
réalisé à quel point
[Musique]
quand la sonde Cassini a atteint Saturne
personnel du centre d'opérations du JPL
j'ai regardé avec impatience pour avoir la confirmation qu'il
avait effectué son insertion orbitale
instructions
[Musique]
il est arrivé en juillet 2004 après un voyage
qui a duré près de sept ans
et il devait effectuer un travail précis
brûlure alignée de 95 minutes pour entrer dans un environnement hautement
orbite excentrique
[Musique]
en raison des grandes distances impliquées
l'engin doit fonctionner de manière autonome
les instructions à Cassini sont envoyées longtemps
le temps à l'avance via l'espace profond
Réseau
signaux confirmant qu'il était entré en
l'orbite a mis 85 minutes pour atteindre la Terre
[Musique]
après six mois en orbite autour de Saturne Cassini
s'est approché de la plus grande lune de Titan Saturne
à ce stade, il avait déjà survolé
Titan capturant plusieurs fois le radar et
des images photographiques cette fois
a lancé une sonde Lander Huygens
Titan est si grand qu'il peut contenir un épais
ambiance donc Huygens était équipé de
un bouclier thermique et un parachute
alors qu'il flottait vers le
surface que le Lander a commencé à prendre
photographies et analyse des
les gaz constitutifs de l'atmosphère
il a effectué le premier atterrissage en douceur dans le
système solaire externe et bien qu'il
a bien fonctionné en relayant les données vers
Cassini n'est qu'un des orbiteurs
les enregistreurs étaient allumés, la moitié des images étaient
perdu
nous savons maintenant que Titan a des lacs sur son
Lacs de surface de méthane liquide
la sonde Cassini est active depuis
plus de 10 ans et pendant cette période
ça nous a aidé à découvrir l'étrange
comportement de Saturne
au début, il semblait que le nord et
hémisphères sud de la géante gazeuse
tournaient à des rythmes différents mais il
il apparaît maintenant que le vent accélère dans le
Le sud est plus rapide
[Musique]
l'orbite de bouclage est régulièrement modifiée donc
qu'il peut passer à proximité de caractéristiques qui
les spécialistes de mission veulent étudier
une autre lune saturnienne Encelade
surpris les observateurs, c'est un dixième du
taille de Titan, mais il semble contenir un
fine atmosphère de vapeur d'eau
les observations suggèrent que cette atmosphère est
être réapprovisionné en eau froide
volcans près du pôle Sud
Cassini est équipé d'une masse
spectromètre et il a pu détecter
eau salée et divers hydrocarbures
on pense maintenant qu'un océan salé
Se trouve sous la croûte glacée d'Encelade
certains physiciens planétaires croient
La boucle d'oreille intérieure de Saturne reçoit son
particules d'Encelade
en 2008, Cassini a été rebaptisé Equinox
Mission et récemment, il a reçu un autre
extension et est devenu le Cassini
Mission Solstice
cela prend à Saturne environ 30 années terrestres
orbiter autour du Soleil et, comme la Terre, son
l'axe est incliné donc il y a des saisons
quand Cassini est arrivé au nord de la planète
Poles in Shadow et ce n'est que récemment
que la sonde pourrait capturer des images de
le vortex polaire hexagonal particulier
ce motif hexagonal a été le premier
observé dans les années 1980 par le Voyager
mission
comme le printemps dans le nord de Saturne
L'hémisphère a connu deux tempêtes géantes
ont été vus en développement, ils nous ont montré chaud
taches dans la partie infrarouge du
spectre, les deux se déplaçant vers le
Ouest
la plus grosse tempête s'est finalement déplacée plus vite
engloutissant le plus petit
même après des perturbations dans le cloud
les schémas avaient encore dissipé la tempête
enregistré dans l'infrarouge
les anneaux orbitent au-dessus de l'équateur de Saturne
s'étendant de six mille à cent
et vingt mille kilomètres au-dessus du
surface pourtant ils ne font que 20 mètres
épais, ils sont faits de glace avec des particules
tailles allant de la poussière fine à 10 mètres
morceaux
[Musique]
il y a des touffes dans les anneaux qui
ont changé depuis les visites du voyageur
au début des années 80 avec l'effervescence intérieure
semblant varier sur une période de plusieurs semaines
Saturne a au moins 150 lunes et
On pense que les lunes dans les Anneaux
perturber les particules
vers la fin de sa mission avec du carburant
à court d'eau, la trajectoire risquée sera
commencer
Cassini passera entre la planète et
son anneau le plus intérieur où la chance de
la collision avec des débris en orbite est
Extrême
il échantillonnera la haute atmosphère et
découvrez la masse des Anneaux
pour éviter une éventuelle contamination du
lunes fragiles, Cassini sera finalement
s'est écrasé sur Saturne
en 2005, le Mars reconnaissance Orbiter
se dirigeait vers ce qui allait devenir le
ciel bondé au-dessus de la planète rouge Mars
Géomètre mondial Mars Express et Mars
Odyssey était en orbite autour de Mars et
l'esprit et l'opportunité des Rovers
à la surface
mais le mro a beaucoup de tâches différentes
tout ouvrant la voie au futur Mars
missions et aboutissant à un équipage
atterrir sur la planète rouge dans environ 15
ans qu'il a cartographié Mars in fine
détail et cette information a déjà
été utilisé pour sélectionner un site d'atterrissage pour
l'atterrisseur Phénix
l'Orbiter collecte également des informations détaillées
informations sur les conditions météorologiques
sur Mars
tout en continuant à transmettre un message plus clair
photo de la planète de retour sur terre
la nouvelle Rover prenait forme, une Rover comme
aucun avant et celui qui fonctionnerait très bien
en étroite collaboration avec le mro
Lockheed Martin sous la supervision de
Le laboratoire de propulsion à réaction de la NASA a été
construire un Rover de la taille d'une petite voiture
contrairement aux Rovers précédents, il n'utiliserait pas
panneaux solaires pour son énergie
il est équipé d'un radio-isotope
générateur thermoélectrique avec un minimum
durée de vie de 14 ans
connu sous le nom de curiosité, le Rover a une gamme
de caméras et d'outils d'analyse chimique
ainsi qu'un bras robotique et des radiations
détecteur
avant de pouvoir voler, il fallait que la curiosité soit
testé à des températures extrêmes et
vibration
vers la fin de 2011, la curiosité a été fixée
dans sa descente d'entrée et son atterrissage
Le module était emballé dans le cône avant de
un atlas V
en raison de la proximité de Mars,
la fenêtre de lancement était extrêmement étroite trois
deux un ont fait l'étoile ninja zéro et le décollage
il faudrait plus de huit heures à l'engin
mois pour atteindre Mars
l'étage supérieur du Centaure a poussé l'engin
hors de l'orbite terrestre sur un trans Mars
trajectoire
avant de séparer la Curiosity
le paquet a été mis en rotation pour plus de stabilité
[Musique]
l'ensemble de croisière était équipé de
radiateurs pour maintenir des températures stables
pour les sous-systèmes critiques qui sont restés
en sommeil pendant la phase de croisière
les cellules solaires fournissent de l'énergie pour
communication avec le contrôle de mission et
les propulseurs sont utilisés pour le cours
Corrections
[Musique]
d'accord
des choses qui ont l'air bien
à l'approche de Mars, l'équipe de la NASA
le laboratoire de propulsion à réaction attendait
10 minutes avant d'atteindre Mars
ambiance l'étape de la croisière était
largué et un incroyablement complexe
la séquence d'événements était sur le point de se dérouler
[Musique]
en entrant dans l'atmosphère, c'était
voyageant à environ 20 000 kilomètres par
heure et la première étape de décélération
a commencé
les propulseurs maintenaient l'engin aligné sur
la Cible sélectionnée à l'aide du
mro
signaux confirmant chaque étape du
La descente a été relayée au JPL via le
Mars
les poids d'équilibrage suivants ont été jetés, donc
l'engin pourrait garder le bon
attitude pour le déploiement du parachute toujours
se déplaçant à 1 600 kilomètres par heure,
petit parachute vide et la chaleur
le bouclier a été jeté
depuis l'orbite, le mro a capturé cette image
de l'étape La Descente
à 1500 mètres L'étape Descente
séparé de la coque arrière et du
les propulseurs d'atterrissage se sont allumés
[Musique]
un altimètre radar surveillait à la fois le
La hauteur de l'engin et sa vitesse
à une hauteur de 20 mètres et maintenant en mouvement
à trois kilomètres par heure, le Rover
a été descendu sur les câbles et les roues
déployé
quand il était sur un sol ferme, il a tiré
pyros coupant les câbles
la technique de la grue céleste a été utilisée pour que
la poussière et les débris soulevés par le
Les roquettes ne pouvaient pas endommager le Rover
la plupart de ces gens du JPL ont consacré
une grande partie de leur vie à cela
projet, c'était la première fois qu'un tel
l'atterrissage avait été tenté et il avait
été impeccable
presque immédiatement, une image a été relayée
dos
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en utilisant l'un de ses systèmes d'évitement des dangers
la curiosité des caméras avait envoyé une image de
la surface et la reconnaissance de Mars
Orbiter jouait un rôle essentiel en tant que
Centre de communication
il enregistre les signaux envoyés par le Rover
émetteur UHF et les retransmet
quand il peut voir la Terre
la curiosité avait été déposée près du
Cratère Gale juste au sud de Martien
équateur
initialement, le Rover a commencé à transmettre
des informations détaillées sur son système
statut et sa descente et son atterrissage
expérience
lors de ses premiers jours sur Mars Les Rovers
maintenant, le programme de vol redondant a été abandonné
et remplacé par une opération en surface
logiciel
son mât de caméra a été étendu et
la curiosité a commencé à changer complètement
façon dont nous pensons à Mars
merci
[Musique]
Je pense
très bien ici
[Musique]
nous allons dans une belle vallée vraiment incroyable
le champ magnétique terrestre s'affaiblit
et les pôles magnétiques dérivent
la constellation de satellites en essaim est
essayer de découvrir ce qui se passe
au cœur en fusion de notre planète
étranger
es-tu capable de voir dans les fenêtres de
six très facilement et vice versa le
missions combinées Gemini six et sept
avait volé en formation mais un original
objectif de rallier deux métiers
ensemble en orbite un processus connu sous le nom de
l'amarrage n'a pas pu être tenté car
Gemini sixes agena Le véhicule cible avait
a explosé juste après le lancement
voir très clairement les scanners Horizon
fonctionner
toutes les missions Gemini restantes seraient
inclure Rendez-vous et l'amarrage et
Gemini 8 avec Neil, astronaute pour la première fois
Armstrong et Dave Scott seraient les prochains
tous les astronautes de la NASA doivent être qualifiés
les pilotes et l'agence spatiale exploite ses
propre aile d'avions d'entraînement à réaction T-38
pour prolonger leurs heures de vol, les astronautes
se déplacent souvent eux-mêmes entre les installations
à travers les États-Unis dans l'un de ces
deux places
Elliott C et Charles Bassett le
Les astronautes qui devaient piloter Gemini 9 sont morts
dans de mauvaises conditions météorologiques lorsque leur
Le T-38 s'est écrasé sur un bâtiment à
Usine d'avions McDonald à St Louis
ils allaient inspecter leur
le vaisseau spatial Gemini 9 deviendrait Tom
La mission de Stafford et Gene Cernan chacun
le vol avait un équipage de secours qui pouvait prendre
malgré le court préavis, la NASA était toujours en
pressé
le 16 mars 1966, Gemini 8 attendait
sur la rampe de lancement 19 alors que vous étiez sur une cible Nagina
véhicule attendu sur le pad 40. l'agina
serait lancé 95 minutes avant le
Le vaisseau Gemini et les deux accosteraient
environ six heures après le lancement
mais l'amarrage n'était pas le seul objectif du
La mission Gemini 8 que Dave Scott devait réaliser
y faire la deuxième sortie dans l'espace de l'Amérique
il y a eu des revers dans le programme Gemini
et ce vol avait pour but de rattraper
[Musique]
alors qu'Armstrong et Scott étaient
attachée à leur embarcation, l'agina était
dans les dernières secondes de son compte à rebours
Obscurité
Les contrôleurs de mission ont confiance dans l'ajina
avait été secoué après le précédent
le véhicule avait explosé au contact de
la deuxième étape mais peu de temps après
lancement, il y a eu la confirmation que cela
agena attendrait correctement dans
orbite et Gemini 8 est arrivé
l'agena était censé être
contrôlable depuis le sol ou depuis le
vaisseau spatial mais parce qu'il y avait eu
difficulté à recevoir des informations de
le contrôle de mission du vaisseau cible est toujours
j'avais des doutes sur l'attitude du genre
Système de contrôle
[Musique]
avant d'accoster, l'équipage a été averti de
éteindre leur système de genre s'il donne
inquiéter
la manœuvre d'amarrage s'est si bien déroulée
que l'équipe au sol était d'abord incertaine
que c'était vraiment arrivé
[Musique]
problèmes lorsque le métier lié a commencé
tourne et ne répond pas au contrôle
immédiatement Armstrong s'est détaché mais le
la rotation s'est aggravée avec les astronautes
danger de s'évanouir
ils ont lancé un retour d'urgence vers
Terre
une analyse ultérieure a disculpé l'agina
révélant que l'un des Gemini Craft
les propulseurs étaient restés bloqués
le vol avait duré moins de 11 heures
les deux fabriqués ne sont restés amarrés que pendant
30 minutes et ils n'étaient pas là
sortie dans l'espace
pourtant, les planificateurs de la mission ont noté un calme et
manière professionnelle qu'Armstrong avait
géré ce qui aurait pu être une tragédie
Armstrong et Scots ont amerri dans le
Pacifique près du Japon, le seul vaisseau Gemini
ne pas atterrir dans l'Atlantique
après l'échec de l'Atlas Agena
Véhicule cible pour le Gemini 6 original
Mission, ses créateurs ont été soulagés qu'elle
avait bien performé pour le Gemini 8
mission
certains ont déclaré que les difficultés étaient dues à
le mélange de différentes entreprises construisant
le thème avec convoyeur faisant l'atlas
premier étage Lockheed faisant le supérieur
agena met en scène un McDonald responsable de
l'adaptateur d'accueil
en mai 1966
gatv9 était prêt pour le lancement, il le ferait
soyez la cible d'accueil de Gemini 9
[Musique]
étranger
les deux premières minutes se sont parfaitement déroulées mais
après cela, un court-circuit a provoqué le droit
moteur d'appoint au cardan dur au-dessus du
la fusée s'est retournée et s'est dirigée vers
l'océan où il s'est écrasé
responsabilité acceptée
comme avec Gemini 6, cela laissait deux
astronautes assis dans un plein plein de carburant
Titan qui n'a nulle part où aller
Tom Stafford avait été impliqué dans deux
le pad abandonne avec Gemini 6 et maintenant ça
avec Gemini 9 a été surnommé le maire de
pavé 19.
mais cette fois un véhicule d'amarrage en attente
était disponible
l'étage supérieur n'avait pas de propulsion mais il
il avait un collier d'amarrage qu'il a lancé
deux semaines plus tard
Gemini 9 désormais rebaptisé Gemini 9A devait
suivre sous peu mais trois minutes avant
le décollage prévu des ordinateurs au sol
perdu le contact avec les ordinateurs Gemini
avec seulement une fenêtre de 40 secondes le lancement
a été lavé
deux jours plus tard, ils ont réessayé
ce serait la sixième fois que le commandant
Stafford avait été attaché avec seulement
une mission terminée
rapidement rattrapé leur orbite
Cible mais quelque chose d'autre s'est mal passé
le carénage de protection ne s'était pas détaché
des techniciens inexpérimentés avaient enregistré
les longes en fibre de verre et ils ont gardé
les deux pièces ensemble
Stafford l'a surnommé l'alligator en colère
Des ingénieurs sur le terrain désespérément
j'ai cherché une solution mais il y en avait aussi
beaucoup de risques pour les astronautes
il n'y aurait pas d'amarrage à ce sujet
mission
[Musique]
Ensuite, Cernan a quitté la capsule où il devait se rendre.
tester une nouvelle unité de manœuvre mais son
la fréquence cardiaque a augmenté de manière si alarmante que le
les médecins lui ont ordonné de rentrer à l'intérieur, il était
surchauffe et son casque était embué
John Young commanderait le prochain
mission Gémeaux 10.
son partenaire serait Michael Collins
effectuant son premier vol, il devait également
faire la prochaine sortie dans l'espace et j'étais
entraînement dans un berceau flottant dans les airs
c'était pour lui donner la pratique d'utiliser le
pistolet zip mais jusqu'à présent, les sorties dans l'espace étaient
présentant des difficultés inattendues dues
au surmenage, cela avait l'air relaxant
les vols Gemini commençaient à
se conformer à un modèle au sein d'Égine
Lancement du véhicule cible 100minutes
avant le vaisseau spatial habité
cette fois, il n'y a eu aucun retard de lancement
les astronautes avaient un emploi du temps chargé
devoir combler les lacunes
des deux vols précédents
l'agina les attendait exactement
comme prévu, Rendez-vous devenait maintenant
routine jeune et Collins rattrapé
et après presque six heures, ils avaient
amarré
Gemini 10 a utilisé une 82e rafale du
moteur de genre pour les propulser à un niveau supérieur
orbite où ils ont visité un Nagina depuis
le vol Gemini 8
[Musique]
leurs exercices de rendez-vous et d'amarrage
s'était bien passé mais l'activité en dehors du
le vaisseau spatial avait encore été difficile avec
la combinaison spatiale gonflée limitant les mouvements
et des équipements importants sont perdus
sur le vol Gemini 11 suivant
Richard Gordon a également eu de grandes difficultés
performer efficacement en dehors du métier
La NASA a proposé une nouvelle formation
technique celle qu'ils ont utilisée à ce jour
la plongée sous-marine était considérée comme une bonne chose
entraînement pour le fitness et régulier
respirant maintenant, ils avaient construit une maquette de
la combinaison Gemini agena dans un haut
piscine scolaire à Baltimore
avec seulement 60 jours avant Gemini 12. Buzz
Aldrin a commencé à pratiquer son programme
routine
en plus de sa combinaison spatiale, il portait
28 kilos de plomb pour lui donner un
flottabilité neutre
Heather a été conçue pour résoudre le
problème que les astronautes précédents avaient eu
je reste juste au même endroit
les commentaires détaillés d'Aldrin ont aidé
Les ingénieurs positionnent les poignées pour faire
activité extra-véhiculaire Eva plus
précis
merci
[Musique]
Le 11 novembre 1966 et l'équipe du pad
étaient tous là pour la finale des Gémeaux
mission
Commandant James Lovell et son pilote
Buzz Aldrin est arrivé à leur fusée avec
des pancartes sur le dos disant la fin
de nombreux membres de l'équipe leur souhaitent au revoir
avait passé des années sur ce projet
il y avait eu une suggestion selon laquelle les Gémeaux
12 devrait être retardé pour coïncider avec
le premier lancement de la série Apollo
mais des retards avec le nouveau vaisseau spatial et
son booster géant a rendu cela irréalisable
étranger
[Musique]
c'était comme prévu mais sur le terrain un
anomalie et données de télémétrie suggérées
que le moteur principal de l'Eugene pourrait donner
problèmes alors ils ont annulé le Boost à un
orbite plus élevée comme prévu
[Applaudissements]
le niveau a amarré le vrai vaisseau
[Musique]
le lendemain, quand Aldrin ouvrit le
trappe et déplacé dehors, tout était
différent, les mains courantes faisaient un immense
différence
[Musique]
la manière progressive et délibérée d'Aldrin
déplacé n'a posé aucun problème d'effort ou
en surchauffe, il a facilement complété tous ses
tâches, y compris attacher une attache
entre les Gémeaux et l'agena
étranger
ils sont restés connectés c'est un
technique que la NASA voulait tester mais a
n'a pas été utilisé depuis
[Musique]
Le projet Gemini s'est terminé sur une bonne note
Jim Lovell avait établi un nouveau record pour le
la plupart des heures passées dans l'espace et son Pilot Buzz
Aldrin a eu plus d'heures d'Eva que quiconque
autre
[Musique]
les missions Gemini avaient réalisé tout
ils avaient décidé de faire
[Musique]
Le 6 août 2012 et Curiosity de la NASA
Le rover est en sécurité à la surface de Mars
[Musique]
les premières semaines ont été consacrées à
reprogrammation du Rover et calibrage
sa suite d'instruments
le Rover avait atterri dans le cratère Gale
cicatrice laissée après un impact de météore plus
il y a plus de 3 milliards d'années
Le cratère Gale avait été choisi parce qu'il
montre des signes que l'eau avait été autrefois
présent
la curiosité se porte sur l'eau et ses
effet sur les premières années du rouge
planète
en particulier si cela aurait pu
vie assistée
[Musique]
étranger
le Rover est équipé d'un certain nombre de
caméras spécialisées sur le mât central
sont deux caméras qui fournissent des images dans
vraie couleur et leur sensibilité s'étend
au-delà du spectre visuel
Une caméra a un champ de vision de 15 degrés
tandis que l'autre fournit un 5 plus étroit
vue degré les deux ont huit gigaoctets de
mémoire flash
[Musique]
Curiosity a deux ordinateurs qu'ils
coordonner les transmissions radio en retour
vers la Terre soit directement via la bande X
émetteur ou avec UHF via Mars
orbiteurs
le relais via les orbiteurs est préférable car
cela donne un débit de données plus élevé
[Musique]
également sur le mât du Rover se trouvent deux noirs
et des caméras de navigation blanches conçues pour
fournir une vue 3D au personnel au sol
tracer le chemin que le Rover prendra
la première grande destination de la curiosité était
Mont pointu s'élevant à 5 500 mètres d'altitude
le fond du cratère
mais il a fallu environ deux ans pour obtenir
là car le terrain est jonché de
caractéristiques que le planétaire
les enquêteurs veulent examiner
le Rover est capable de naviguer
de manière autonome mais il s'appuie toujours sur
instructions de la propulsion à réaction de la NASA
laboratoire pour régler à courte portée
destinations
les images sauvegardées par des produits chimiques
l'analyse montre sans équivoque que l'eau
était autrefois présent sur ce site
[Musique]
également logé dans le mât de curiosité est un
laser qui fonctionne en conjonction avec un
suite d'instruments connue sous le nom de Ken cam
jusqu'à sept mètres, il peut
vaporiser un petit échantillon et analyser son
composition chimique
[Musique]
si un examen plus approfondi d'un ours rocheux
percer au bout du robot du Rover
le bras peut extraire un échantillon
[Musique]
le bras dispose également d'un spectromètre à rayons X
et un imageur capable de capturer des images
jusque dans les moindres détails microscopiques
[Musique]
la poudre extraite de la roche est versée
dans l'ouverture du chem-min
instrument utilisant des rayons X
peut identifier la teneur en minéraux du
rock les premiers échantillons que Curiosity
testé a révélé du soufre, de l'azote et de l'hydrogène
oxygène, phosphore et carbone
et pourtant, il y a eu des problèmes quelques mois seulement
dans sa mission, l'ordinateur principal
est passé en mode sans échec en utilisant la sauvegarde
ordinateur, il a fallu trois jours au personnel du JPL pour
restaurer le système
[Musique]
et les roues en métal léger de la curiosité sont
commence à montrer des signes de dommages
certains rochers sont à la fois très déchiquetés et
fermement ancré dans le sol martien qui
les conducteurs de Rover doivent réfléchir
plus attentivement sur les chemins qu'ils
sélectionner
le Rover dispose de deux détecteurs de rayonnement
et les informations provenant de ceux-ci suggèrent que
une mission habitée sur la planète rouge
ne pas être indûment troublé par des
niveaux de rayonnement
la prochaine phase de la mission de curiosité
je le verrai gravir les pentes du Mont
Pointu
Les spécialistes de mission sont enthousiasmés par
les différentes strates de roche qu'ils attendent
trouver
un flux de particules chargées émane
du soleil
connu sous le nom de vent solaire, il coule
dans tout le système solaire
pendant une activité solaire extrême coronale
des éjections massives bombardent les planètes
la Terre est largement protégée par son
champ magnétique mais dans les régions polaires
où convergent les lignes du champ magnétique
les particules chargées peuvent descendre en spirale et
interagir avec la haute atmosphère
se manifestant par des aurores
nous savons d'après les caractéristiques géologiques de la Terre
enregistrer que les pôles se retournent de manière imprévisible
entre cent mille et 50
millions d'années et au cours des 150 dernières
années, le champ magnétique terrestre a
a diminué en intensité d'environ 15
pour cent
[Musique]
pour en savoir plus sur notre planète
champ magnétique fluctuant européen
L'Agence spatiale a lancé un trio de capteurs magnétiques
satellites d'observation appelés essaim
les trois satellites identiques mesurent
à la fois la force et la direction du
Le champ magnétique terrestre continue
évoluer
[Musique]
une heure de lancement, ils ont chacun déployé un
magnétomètre placé à l'extrémité d'un
boom pour l'isoler de tout champ parasite
générés par les satellites Electronique
[Musique]
appelé alpha bravo et Charlie le trio
sont livrés avec précision au nord-sud
orbites à une hauteur de 490 kilomètres
les oscillations du boom prendraient
plusieurs minutes pour se stabiliser
au fil du temps, Alpha et Charlie suivront
le même chemin et leurs orbites seront
autorisé à se décomposer, Brava conservera son
altitude de lancement mais c'est progressivement
dériver vers un plan orbital différent
cela permettra aux chercheurs d'acquérir une
vue en trois dimensions de
magnétosphère
[Musique]
bien que la majeure partie de la Terre
est généré par le mouvement à l’intérieur du
noyau de fer fondu
Le magnétisme solaire est retenu dans les zones de
courants rocheux et d'eau salée dans le
les océans contribuent également
[Musique]
les satellites Swarm permettront
chercheurs pour construire une carte dynamique de
l'intérieur de la planète
ils veulent comprendre pourquoi le magnétique
le champ diminue et pourquoi la Terre
les pôles magnétiques dérivent
Il y a 780 000 ans les pôles magnétiques
renversé et les chercheurs veulent savoir
si les fluctuations actuelles sont
symptômes de l'approche d'un autre
inversion de champ
une zone faible dans la magnétosphère au-dessus
l'Atlantique Sud permet le vent solaire
pénétrer à des altitudes plus basses
plus de satellites échouent en passant au-dessus de cela
région qu'ailleurs
les connaissances acquises grâce à l'essaim ont
implications Au-delà du sensible
L'électronique continue de s'affaiblir
le champ magnétique permettra plus d'énergie solaire
rayonnement pour atteindre la surface de la Terre
avec des implications pour tous les êtres vivants
[Musique]
l'agence spatiale européenne a été
envoyer des astronautes profondément sous terre alors que
formation pour les séjours prolongés sur le
Station spatiale internationale
étranger
[Musique]
au début des années 60 pendant le Mercure
programme que les États-Unis ont commencé
développer un booster géant capable de
transportant un équipage de trois personnes sur la Lune
utilisé un groupe de chars à l'origine
conçu pour les autres rockers et le premier
les vols viennent de tester un mammouth plus bas
étape, il est devenu connu sous le nom de celui de Saturne
les lancements ont commencé en 1961, mais même si
pourrait soulever de lourdes dépressions avec notre partie supérieure
le met en scène
dans chaque orbite
Les ingénieurs s'attendaient à l'habituel
problèmes de démarrage avec le grand nouveau
fusée mais il n'y en avait pas à chaque lancement
s'est déroulé comme prévu
en même temps le nouveau beaucoup plus grand
Le vaisseau spatial Apollo était en cours de développement
la version initiale du bloc 1 a été conçue
quand la NASA envisageait encore la capsule
avec un grand module de descente et de retour
atterrirait directement sur la lune
[Musique]
étranger
les modèles ont été construits comme articles de test
avant que la NASA ne choisisse un bloc modifié
2 modèles comprenant une sonde d'accueil
et travaillerait en collaboration avec un
péniche d'atterrissage lunaire
comme les précédents vaisseaux spatiaux américains, le
Capsules Apollo conçues pour atterrir dans le
océan, chaque situation était rigoureusement
testés et parfois la valeur de ceux-ci
les tests n'étaient que vraiment évidents
la capsule Apollo était équipée d'un
tour d'évasion comme son Mercure
prédécesseur dans un capteur d'urgence
déclencherait les fusées à combustible solide
ce qui éloignerait l'engin d'un
booster explosif
cela a été testé par un laboratoire spécialement
conçu Little Joe Rocket
lors des tests en 1965, le Little Joe était
destiné à tester un abandon à haute altitude mais
seulement 26 secondes après le début du vol, le
la fusée a développé un rôle
c'était une véritable urgence et le
le système avait parfaitement fonctionné
partout aux États-Unis, différents Apollo
les sous-systèmes étaient en cours de test
simultanément
même si la NASA sentait désormais qu'elle avait atteint
parité avec la capacité technique russe
J'étais toujours dans une course vers la lune
concentré sur la fin du président Kennedy
le délai de dix ans
merci
[Musique]
c'était une prouesse d'organisation magistrale
La NASA a bénéficié d'un financement généreux et
soutien populaire auprès des États-Unis
en passant par une technique dirigée par l'espace
Révolutionnez le film rival d'un astronaute
les stars en tant que figures de l'adulation du public
en février 1966, un Saturn 1B était prêt
pour un test complet sans pilote
c'était une nouvelle technique pour la NASA
tester signifiait tester une gamme de nouveaux
systèmes dans un seul vol
si tout va bien, cela nous ferait gagner beaucoup de temps
un engagement de lancement nul, nous avons un décollage
tous les moteurs construisent la confiance
déménager
le Saturne, un étage inférieur, avait été
amélioré et était maintenant connu sous le nom de s1b
cette fois, il y avait une deuxième étape
s4b la combinaison soulèverait un bloc 1
version du vaisseau spatial Apollo pour son
premier vol
les capsules éclaboussées dans le
Atlantic 37 minutes après le lancement
la mission a été globalement un succès
même s'il s'agissait de problèmes de moteur et
des problèmes de câblage ont entraîné une perte de
contrôle de la direction et distorsions dans
Données de télémétrie
l'attention s'est maintenant déplacée vers le premier
vol habité
Gus Grissom l'un des Mercure originaux
7 astronautes
Ed White, le premier Américain à entrer
espace
et le débutant Roger Chaffee ferait l'équipage
un bloc à l'ancienne d'une capsule Apollo dans
une mission prévue pour février 1967.
Grissom avait accompli un travail précieux dans le
développement du vaisseau spatial Gemini et
il avait commandé la première mission Gemini
il avait assumé un rôle similaire auprès du
nouveau module de commande Apollo mais il était
devenir frustré
il était préoccupé par le décalage entre
modifications apportées au module de commande et
les modifications correspondantes au
simulateurs
la quantité de matière inflammable qui
était dans le compartiment de l'équipage était également
soulevé plusieurs fois
alors que la technologie du booster était
progressant régulièrement à mesure que
la complexité du vaisseau spatial était visible
il est en retard sur le calendrier
La NASA découvrait de nombreuses lacunes
avec la qualité fournie par l'entrepreneur
Aviation nord-américaine
un autre aspect du travail de l'astronaute
impliquait un engagement sans cesse croissant envers
les médias de masse
depuis sa création, la NASA avait décidé
que ses activités seraient toutes ouvertes à
l'examen public contrairement à l'Amérique
Adversaire de la guerre froide, l’Union soviétique
qui a choisi de cacher son programme spatial
en secret
Le bureau des affaires publiques de la NASA est embauché
des journalistes qui ont compris ce qui fonctionnait
les journalistes avaient besoin, mais il était clair que
les astronautes ont trouvé des photos d'appels
distraction
des journées de presse régulières ont eu lieu au
préparation à la mission
[Musique]
à l'approche du jour du lancement, la formation en
les simulateurs sont passés aux tests du
le vaisseau spatial lui-même parfois dans le vide
chambre et parfois, alors qu'il était assis au sommet de son
booster l'une de ces procédures connues sous le nom de
un test de débranchement visait à évaluer le
Les capsules Apollo fonctionnent alors qu'elles étaient
déconnecté du contrôle de lancement
fonctionnant de manière indépendante et par ses propres moyens
il n'y avait pas de carburant dans le vaisseau spatial ou
dans le booster et tous les pyros et
les boulons explosifs ont été désactivés, donc ceci
était considérée comme une situation très sûre
tous les autres paramètres seraient les mêmes
comme dans un compte à rebours en direct et lancez le
les astronautes respireraient de l'oxygène pur à
légèrement au-dessus de la pression atmosphérique
cette première version de la capsule avait un
trappe de style ancien qui s'ouvrait vers l'intérieur
serait maintenu en place par le
pression
les missions habitées ultérieures auraient un
trappe à ouverture différente vers l'extérieur
pendant des heures le compte à rebours simulé
arrêté et redémarré mais à 6h30
une étincelle a déclenché un incendie éclair
dans un environnement d'oxygène pur, il
a consommé la capsule, tuant les trois
astronautes en quelques secondes
[Musique]
les États-Unis étaient en deuil
Gus Grissom, Ed White et Roger Chaffee
ont été enterrés avec tous les honneurs militaires
merci
beaucoup à la Nasa redoutaient ce genre
du résultat dans un discours prononcé devant des collègues de
Jean, directeur de vol de Mission Control
Krantz a dit
nous étions trop enthousiastes à propos du calendrier
et nous avons verrouillé tous les problèmes que nous
vu chaque jour dans notre travail
les vols habités ont été suspendus
l'agence spatiale devait découvrir ce que
ça s'est mal passé et puis complètement
redessiné la capsule et Mission
procédures
tous les restes d'Apollo ont été saisis et
La NASA a lancé une étude exhaustive
enquête
les deux chambres du Congrès ont également créé
demandes de renseignements
Frank Borman était le seul astronaute à
siéger au comité d'examen des accidents de la NASA
il était l'un des rares astronautes à
servir de commandant lors de sa première mission
Gémeaux 7 et il avait été sélectionné pour
commander la troisième mission Apollo habitée
mais il y avait un nuage sur tout
programme
finalement le témoignage de Borman devant un
le comité de la Chambre a aidé à convaincre le Congrès
que le programme habité Apollo était sûr
reprendre les opérations
[Musique]
enquêtes La NASA a essayé de maintenir son
les astronautes étaient des experts dans tous les domaines
aspect du vol et ingénierie connexe
étaient maintenant envoyés en excursion sur le terrain
en apprendre davantage sur la géologie en vue de
Missions lunaires
bien que les missions habitées pour 1967 aient
été mis en attente NASA toujours programmé
vols
le booster géant Saturn V nécessaire pour obtenir
vers la lune était enfin prêt pour le lancement
il y avait eu des retards avec le deuxième
scène
Apollo 4 serait un autre test complet
qui comprenait le problème Command
Module en livraison de l'entrepreneur Nord
American Aviation, il a été soumis à
examen minutieux
plus de 1400 problèmes ont été découverts
la réponse des responsables de la NASA qui étaient
près des astronautes d'Apollo 1 à distance
De la fureur aux larmes
des travaux correctifs sur le module de commande ont duré
quatre mois avec Apollo 4 enfin prêt
pour un lancement en novembre 1967.
la nouvelle fusée était couverte de capteurs
et les caméras enregistreraient des critiques
les fonctions
cinq quatre nous avons l'allumage
tous les moteurs tournent
nous avons vécu nous avons vécu à 7 ans
00 h, heure normale de l'Est
construisons un navire
tremblement
la dernière fenêtre tremblait que nous soyons
le tenant avec nos mains
regarde cette fusée à charbon dans les nuages
de trois mille pieds
les caméras destinées à surveiller
les subtilités de la mise en scène ont capturé certains des
les images les plus emblématiques de l'Apollon
programme
ils ont été largués peu de temps après
les photos ont été capturées et parachutées
de retour pour une récupération des océans
à ce stade, personne ne savait si
L'objectif du président Kennedy d'une lune
L'atterrissage à la fin de la décennie était
réalisable et la tragédie d'Apollo 1 a été
ce qui fait que beaucoup d'Américains ont la deuxième place
réflexions sur la course vers la lune
étranger
[Musique]
sur la Station spatiale internationale
implique une démarche scientifique très spécifique
tâches combinées au fait de devoir gérer
avec l'inattendu
et bien que Ground Control fournira
Un conseil : les astronautes doivent être ingénieux
et bon pour résoudre les problèmes, l'espace est un
environnement hostile et leur vie
ça pourrait en dépendre
dans le cadre de la formation des astronautes Esa
organise régulièrement un exercice de grottes où
astronautes de tout le partenaire de l'ISS
les agences viennent travailler ensemble dans
système de grottes de Sagruta en Sardaigne
[Musique]
Issa gère des grottes depuis huit ans
années, c'est un acronyme alambiqué de
Aventure coopérative pour valoriser et
exercer un comportement humain et
compétences de performance
l'absence d'un cycle sensoriel jour-nuit
privation d'espaces claustrophobes et un
besoin absolu d'un bon travail d'équipe
un analogue fort avec le vol spatial
chaque nouveau groupe se réunit pour une formation
programme qui est aussi multiculturel
exercice de consolidation d'équipe
[Musique]
contre les spéléologues a informé les astronautes
ce à quoi ils peuvent s'attendre, cette équipe le fera
mais je passe six jours dans les grottes
les expéditions précédentes ont été
sous terre pendant deux semaines
la formation de la Cave n'est pas seulement un
test d'endurance que l'équipe devrait réaliser
faire des recherches sérieuses l'année dernière
groupe a découvert une nouvelle espèce de
crustacé dans les grottes
les participants apprennent également la cartographie 3D
compétences et devraient enquêter 1,5
kilomètres de régions largement non cartographiées
système sagruta
[Musique]
avant leur longue expédition souterraine
les astronautes visitent plusieurs petites grottes
de se familiariser avec le
routines
en orbite, ce sont les bras et les jambes de
l'équipe scientifique élargie sur le terrain
et un plan similaire est suivi ici
mesurera le dioxyde de carbone et
niveaux de radon ainsi que la prise
échantillons microbiologiques
ces mesures scientifiques détaillées
sont effectués selon des règles strictes
des lignes directrices
[Musique]
le premier jour de l'expédition,
les astronautes disent au revoir à l'habituel
modèle de jour et de nuit
pour les six prochains jours, la seule lumière
ils auront sera sorti de leur tête
laboratoires
même s'ils suivront toujours un quotidien
routine, il n'y a aucun indice visuel sur le
le passage du temps
Chaque membre de l'équipe porte deux courts
attaches à sa taille
protocoles de sécurité similaires à ceux de l'espace
la marche nécessitent que ceux-ci soient utilisés dans tous
situations dangereuses
inclut l'humidité des grottes sèches et humides
les niveaux dans tout le système sont
uniformément élevée et toute l'année
la température reste à 14 degrés
les équipes passent plusieurs heures à réaliser
se dirigent vers une galerie centrale où
ils installent un camp de base qui servira
comme leur centre d'opérations
les temps sont nécessaires en raison du
gouttes constantes
[Musique]
la disponibilité immédiate de l'eau rend
c'est un bon camping
ici le délégué des instructeurs techniques
toute la planification et la prise de décision
autorité au chef élu de l’équipe
la routine quotidienne s'organise autour
des délais tout comme les équipes sur le
Station spatiale internationale tous les jours
l'activité est planifiée à l'avance
[Musique]
le groupe a exploré deux branches du
système de grottes passant devant une zone nommée
Lac Baïkal et continue vers
des galeries jamais vues auparavant
ils cherchaient un camping avancé
mais je n'ai trouvé aucun endroit approprié
le lendemain, l'équipe a enfilé son
combinaisons, ils exploreraient une rivière
zone cartographiée par l'expédition précédente
[Musique]
depuis un cours d'essai en 2008, plus et
plus de situations similaires au vol spatial
ont été introduits sous terre
étranger
malgré les exigences physiques imposées
les astronautes ne sont pas extrêmes, ils le sont
sous contrainte
le manque de lumière rend le mouvement et
Manipulation du matériel plus difficile et
l'absence de cycle jour-nuit
déforme la perception du temps
[Musique]
Issa pense que l'environnement k offre
une formation exceptionnelle depuis longtemps
durée du vol spatial
étranger
a appelé la salle de bal où le groupe a
atteint les limites de la carte
ils se dirigent vers une région inexplorée
où ils découvrent deux énormes nouveautés
galeries
[Musique]
tout comme dans l'espace faisant une précision
le dossier photographique est une partie importante
des documents
ils décident qu'ils aimeraient établir un
avancez le camp ici mais avant qu'ils puissent
Les protocoles de mission disent qu'ils doivent informer
contrôle des grottes
établir un contact radio à travers plus de
100 mètres de roche solide, c'est impossible
mais ils ont une sorte de numérique
téléphone qui transmet en utilisant le
conductivité du sol humide
[Musique]
les groupes passent encore deux jours dans le
zone enregistrant la population d'insectes
prélèvement d'échantillons d'eau et d'air et cartographie
les galeries
[Musique]
finalement c'était de retour à la surface où
des douches chaudes et des repas cuisinés étaient
en attendant
mais avant de rentrer chez eux, la finale
phase de l'opération doit être
terminé, tous les travaux de recherche doivent être
rédigé et présenté
Le 14 mai 2009 et un Aryen 5
lance le télescope infrarouge Herschel
et l'Observatoire de l'espace planches
la planche a été frappée ajoutée à un lagrangien
orbite autour d'un 0,1 million et demi
kilomètres au-delà de la Terre
son travail consistait à cartographier les variations dans
fond cosmique de micro-ondes ou CMB le
échos restants du Big Bang au
début de l'univers
pour ce faire, il fallait être sensible
sensible aux différences de température
à travers le ciel jusqu'à des millions de
degré
alors qu'il était opérationnel ses détecteurs
devait être réfrigéré à un dixième de
degré au-dessus du zéro absolu, ce qui en fait le
objet le plus froid de l'espace
alors qu'il scrutait le ciel, il pivota avec un
haut degré de précision lui permettant de
faire une carte en trois dimensions de
univers à travers neuf différents
longueurs d'onde
lorsque le CMB a été observé pour la première fois en 1965
il était considéré comme uniforme dans tous
instruments de direction capables de détecter
ses infimes variations n'existaient pas
ouais, des images formées de différentes
les longueurs d'onde donnent des indices sur la formation
des galaxies et les données de Planck ont
changé les idées des cosmologistes sur les premiers
formation d'étoiles
les preuves suggèrent maintenant les premières étoiles
s'est enflammé 140 millions d'années plus tard que
on pensait auparavant
[Musique]
alors que l'Univers primitif refroidissait la lumière
a inondé le ciel comme l'univers
a continué à s'étendre, cette lumière s'est estompée et pourtant
le CMB persiste à donner une image de
l'univers à ses balbutiements
non seulement l'exactitude des informations
de Planck permettant aux cosmologistes de
recalibrer la chronologie de l'univers
sa révision incitant à la théorie de
une inflation qui ne correspond pas à l'image
révélé par l'enquête
[Musique]
Planck a été mis hors service en octobre
2013 quand l'épuisement de son hélium
le liquide de refroidissement l'a rendu inutilisable
[Musique]
belle vallée vraiment incroyable
tester la technologie en apesanteur lunaire
la gravité ou même la gravité martienne
techniques mises au point pour les débuts de l'espace
Le programme trouve des utilisations répandues dans le monde moderne
recherche
étranger
[Musique]
au début de 1968, la NASA était
se prépare à lancer l'Apollo sans pilote
5.
un Saturne 1B soulèverait un véhicule très différent
charge utile en orbite terrestre basse
ça faisait 12 mois depuis trois
les astronautes ont été incinérés en préparation
pour le lancement d'Apollo 1
partisans du programme spatial américain
craignait que les enquêtes menées dans les deux chambres de
Le Congrès mis en place après la tragédie
mettre fin au programme Apollo mais président
Lyndon Johnson qui avait décoré deux de
les astronautes d'Apollo 1 avaient influencé
au Capitole et son soutien continu
car la NASA a aidé à réprimer toute politique
contrecoup
les travaux sur une capsule Apollo redessinée ont été
progresser
mais la précipitation pour rencontrer le président Kennedy
date limite de fin de décennie samedi
mal à l'aise avec le besoin de
précision et qualité
tous les matériaux inflammables ont été
éliminé d'un vaisseau spatial et
combinaisons spatiales au lancement des astronautes
ne respirerait plus d'oxygène pur et
la trappe complexe avait été remplacée par un
unité monobloc pouvant être ouverte
rapidement
plus de 1 400 problèmes de câblage ont été
corrigée
mais il y avait un élément essentiel du
Programme Apollo qui n'a pas été testé
rien de tel n'avait jamais volé
la péniche d'atterrissage lunaire connue sous le nom de
le module lunaire avait été en proie à
problèmes de développement et son premier test
le vol avait été retardé de près de 12 heures
mois
il s'agissait d'un étage de descente qui
resterait sur la lune et une Ascension
scène qui ramènerait les astronautes
au module de commande Apollo en attente
orbite lunaire, chaque partie avait son propre moteur
[Musique]
lors des tests, le moteur Descent n'avait pas
brûlait doucement de tout l'Apollo
Matériel auquel ce moteur devait répondre
le contrôle le plus délicat
des tests rigoureux ont finalement résolu ce problème
problème et le LM1 était préparé pour le vol
l'Apollo 5 sans pilote testerait le
vaisseau en orbite terrestre
le module lunaire emballé sous le
Le cône de nez unique n'avait pas de pattes d'atterrissage car
ceux-ci auraient encore retardé
livraison
et après des tests de pression sur le LM5,
une fenêtre explosée lm1 avait de l'aluminium
des panneaux au lieu du verre dans ses fenêtres
RTC utilisera la sélection de site Guido sur
Le 22 janvier 1968, le programme en deux étapes
Saturne 1B était ravitaillée et attendait
Cap Canaveral, bloc 37b
[Musique]
transmission
programme 11. 11.
rouler mi démarrer pas roulant
cette mission sera jugée entièrement sur
Télémétrie sur le flux électronique de
des capteurs surveillant chaque système dans le
booster et le module lunaire
à la fin du vol, rien ne se passerait
retourner sur Terre
La NASA avait besoin de savoir comment fonctionne la Lune
les modules de descente et les moteurs de montée seraient
fonctionner dans l'espace
un problème logiciel a stoppé une descente
le moteur brûle après seulement quatre secondes mais
Mission Control a pu reprogrammer
il
après 11 heures, tous les systèmes étaient
vérifié et la mission a déclaré un
succès
les astronautes n'en auraient qu'un
possibilité de piloter l'engin et deux
différents types de simulateurs ont été
développé pour la formation
le centre de recherche sur l'alunissage à
Langley a exposé les astronautes à ce type de
des décisions qu'ils auraient à prendre
pendant les 50 derniers mètres de leur
descente vers la surface lunaire
mais c'était un peu comme un carnaval
et les astronautes préféraient le gratuit
simulateur de vol connu sous le nom de lunaire
Véhicule de recherche à l'atterrissage ou LL RV
il était surnommé le sommier volant
un moteur à réaction à cardan fourni partiellement
ascenseur qui a aidé l'engin à se comporter comme il
était sous l'influence de la gravité lunaire
le reste de l'ascenseur et le contrôle
provenait de Rockets étranglables similaires
à ceux du module lunaire
comme n'importe quel autre avion, il devait
être minutieusement testé par un pilote d'essai de la NASA
Joe Walker a réalisé la première série de
vols en 1964.
il pourrait décoller et voler en utilisant le jet
moteur puis passer en mode sim
quand il se comporterait comme le lunaire
module
en 1967, Neil Armstrong fut le premier
astronaute pour piloter le prototype
l'année suivante, il a piloté un avion modifié
version avec parois de cockpit limitées
sa vision de quelque chose comme il l'avait vu
à travers la fenêtre du module lunaire
lors de la commutation en mode SIM, la réponse
Le contrôle du pilote est devenu lent à mesure que
aussi proche que les experts pourraient le faire
façon dont le module lunaire se comporterait
gravité lunaire
plus tard, les astronautes appelleraient le llrv le
héros méconnu du programme Apollo mais
Les administrateurs de la NASA avaient la seconde
pensées
[Applaudissements]
ce ne serait pas le dernier crash
LL RVs et ses dérivés un seul était
laissé à la fin du programme Apollo
le deuxième lancement de Saturn V était le dernier
Mission Apollo sans pilote Apollo 6.
les objectifs d’action comprenaient le suivi
la quantité de vibrations à pleine charge
Saturne V connaîtrait
il transportait un module lunaire factice et
un module hybride de commande et de service
comme Apollo 4, ce n'était pas seulement couvert
avec des capteurs mais
cas2
c'était la première fois que le Saturn V était
transportant une charge complète, les ingénieurs étaient enthousiastes
pour voir comment ça s'est passé
il y avait des problèmes
deux minutes après le début du vol, vibrations
a parcouru toute la longueur de la fusée
causant des dommages au boîtier de l'adaptateur
le module lunaire
lorsque la deuxième étape a repris deux des
ses moteurs se sont arrêtés prématurément, affectant
orbite finale
le troisième étage a dû brûler plus longtemps pour
compenser
à l'intérieur du module de commande, une caméra était
formé sur la fenêtre
[Musique]
et à diverses parties des astronautes
tableau de bord
après trois orbites, l'étage supérieur
n'a pas réussi à se rallumer comme commandé
La NASA voulait tester la capsule dans un
rentrée à grande vitesse à haute altitude afin que le
module de commande et de service séparés
de l'étage supérieur et a utilisé son propre
moteur pour le propulser sur une orbite plus élevée pour
une rentrée plus rapide
[Musique]
bien qu'Apollo 6 ait été troublé par
difficultés techniques que la NASA a comprises
les problèmes de vibrations et j'ai pu
repenser divers sous-systèmes en fonction
aux informations recueillies au cours de cette
mission
enfin la NASA était prête à en lancer un autre
mission habitée et en octobre 1968
Apollo 7 était prêt à être lancé
il avait une commande complètement repensée
Module et les astronautes porteraient un
une toute nouvelle combinaison spatiale
après le tir d'Apollo 1, la nouvelle combinaison a7l
était résistant au feu avec une couche extérieure
de tissu bêta enduit de téflon
un casque Fishbowl d'une seule pièce qui a fait
loin du besoin d'une visière et d'une visière
le joint était posé sur les épaules
permettant le mouvement de la tête et fournissant
Visibilité supérieure
le matin du 11 octobre 1968
trois astronautes étaient préparés pour le
Le premier vol habité du programme Apollo
serait le dernier Saturn 1B du programme
Mission et ne porterait pas de lunaire
module
vétéran du Mercure et des Gémeaux
programmes Wally Shira et deux premières fois
les astronautes Don Eisley et Walter
Cunningham serait le premier de la NASA
les astronautes voleront dans près de deux ans
étranger
c'est le contrôle de lancement que nous avons autorisé
la tour Roger Tower claire
12 secondes d'arrêt dans le programme roll ont
commencé
la plus grosse capsule Apollo fournissait un
un environnement plus confortable est nécessaire
pour les vols de longue durée qui étaient
nécessaire pour aller sur la lune
l'équipage pouvait décoller ou enfiler son
combinaisons spatiales volumineuses selon les besoins et ils
ils n'étaient pas obligés de rester dans leurs canapés
comme dans les vaisseaux spatiaux Mercury et Gemini
[Musique]
peu après avoir atteint l'orbite, la commande
et module de service séparé du
étage supérieur s4b
lors d'une mission sur la lune, cela se produirait normalement
abriter le module lunaire
l'un des quatre panneaux adaptateurs n'était pas
ouvert entièrement sur les vols suivants ces
se séparerait complètement de la partie supérieure
scène
le vaisseau spatial s'est retourné et
pratiqué l'amarrage à l'aide d'un visuel
Cible de référence qui serait habituellement
monté sur le module lunaire
peu de temps après le début de la mission, Shira est arrivée
avec un rhume et dans les limites de
la capsule s'est rapidement propagée au
deux autres
en apesanteur, la congestion nasale était
ne s'efface pas de la même manière qu'il le ferait
la terre et l'équipage étaient très
manger inconfortable est devenu un point sensible
avec les astronautes même si la nourriture avait
amélioré depuis l'espace précédent
missions les lyophilisés et les bouchées
les repas réhydratants étaient en deçà de ce que
ils ont jugé acceptable
les exigences de cette mission étaient
des échanges très tendus entre
les astronautes malades et Mission Control
n'étaient pas rares, ils devaient tirer avec le
moteur du module de service pas moins de huit
fois
les relations publiques ont atteint de nouveaux sommets
la mission sous forme d'une série d'émissions télévisées
de la capsule ont été surveillés autour du
monde à un moment donné, Shira a refusé de
allumez l’équipement TV car le
l'horaire était trop chargé et l'équipage
je n'avais pas mangé
[Musique]
préparation à la rentrée et à un nouveau conflit
a éclaté, les astronautes ont refusé de porter
leurs casques lors du retour sur Terre
avec leurs rhumes, ils s'inquiétaient du
changements rapides de pression qu'ils voulaient
se boucher le nez et souffler pour égaliser
la pression
[Musique]
à bord du porte-avions Essex l'Apollo 7
les astronautes étaient considérés comme de retour
Héros mais ils n'ont pas reçu le
honneurs habituels de la NASA et Shira Eisley et
Cunningham n'a plus jamais volé
merci
[Musique]
le dioxyde de carbone est un petit mais vital
composant de l'atmosphère de notre planète
le carbone qui constitue la majeure partie
de matière végétale en est extraite
le CO2 atmosphérique à son tour les plantes
reconstituer l'oxygène de l'atmosphère
[Musique]
toute vie animale produit cet oxygène et
exhale du CO2, c'est ce qu'on appelle le carbone
faire du vélo
[Musique]
nos sociétés industrielles modernes dépendent
également de l'oxygène et en brûlant du charbon et
produits pétroliers nous produisons l'énergie
qui alimente nos modes de vie riches
[Musique]
ce processus produit également du dioxyde de carbone
il y a eu une augmentation mesurable de
CO2 atmosphérique depuis la surveillance formelle
des niveaux plus élevés de CO2 signifient que
la couverture d'air de la planète laisse moins passer
la chaleur de la Terre Évadez-vous dans l'espace
provoquant une légère augmentation de la planète
température
conduit à des réductions visibles dans l’Arctique
glace de mer et dans le retrait des glaciers
aux confins du continent Antarctique
en utilisant les relevés météorologiques du monde entier
Monde Institut Godad de la NASA pour l'espace
des études indiquent que 2014 a été la plus chaude
année depuis 1880. le rapport Goddard
a révélé que neuf des 10 plus chauds
les années enregistrées ont toutes été dans ce domaine
siècle
comprendre la géographie
répartition des sources de CO2 et
les régions qui le retirent de l'air
La NASA a commandé un satellite équipé
avec une suite extrêmement précise de
spectromètres pour analyser l'intensité
Concentrations de CO2 dans l'atmosphère
[Musique]
La NASA avait construit un carbone en orbite
Observatoire
le premier satellite Oco lancé en
2009 n'a pas réussi à atteindre l'orbite lorsque le
le carénage de la charge utile ne s'est pas séparé du
vaisseau spatial et il n'a pas pu réaliser
orbite
[Applaudissements]
50 secondes à partir de la pression dynamique
un double observatoire du carbone en orbite
connu sous le nom d'oco2 est entré avec succès dans
Orbite polaire en juillet 2014.
son orbite nord-sud lui permet de
survoler tous les points de la Terre
faire surface au moins une fois tous les 16 jours
[Musique]
il effectue des mesures dans trois
Modes
Le mode Nadia échantillonne l'atmosphère
directement en dessous, donnant un aperçu global
image des concentrations tourbillonnantes
de CO2, cette carte de Goddard était
compilé à partir de mesures au sol
les données d'oco2 fourniront bien plus
détail
deuxième type de fonctionnement Mode cible
permet à l’Observatoire de se concentrer sur un
point d'intérêt unique lui permettant de
rassembler plusieurs lectures qui peuvent être
par rapport aux mesures au sol effectuées
sur le même site
le troisième mode de reflet voit le satellite
échantillon proche du point sur la Terre
surface qui reflète directement les rayons du soleil
rayons, cela améliore encore la
la sensibilité du spectromètre en particulier
lors de l'échantillonnage au-dessus des océans
et oco2 peut détecter l'oxygène
concentrations qui donneront une image claire
indication des taux de croissance des plantes
et leur capacité à agir comme puits de carbone
oco2 restera opérationnel pendant au
au moins deux ans
au début des années 1950, le prédécesseur de la NASA
le comité consultatif national pour
Aéronautique réalisée en vol zéro
tests de gravité
en volant dans un arc parabolique un avion
pourrait compenser la force de gravité pour un
court instant
les premiers tests sur un Lockheed xb80 ont été
rudimentaire
piloter la parabole précise pour maximiser
le temps zéro g était difficile pour les pilotes
pour savoir ce qu'ils en ont appris
expérience de chaton
en 1959, au début de l'activité de la NASA
Le vol parabolique du programme Mercury a été
bien compris et c'est devenu un
partie fondamentale de la formation des astronautes
pour obtenir l'effet, l'avion monte
à un angle de 45 degrés lorsque la poussée est
réduit et le nez de l'avion tombe
les passagers font l'expérience de l'apesanteur
jusqu'à ce que le nez de l'avion atteigne un
angle vers le bas de 30 degrés lorsque le
le pilote se retire de la plongée
étranger
années soixante, la NASA employait deux kc-135
avions pour l'entraînement zéro g, ce sont
la version militaire du Boeing 707
ils étaient surnommés les apesanteurs
merveilles
pendant les astronautes du programme Gemini
devaient désormais marcher dans l'espace et
les vols d'entraînement en apesanteur sont arrivés
dans le leur
avant que Michael Collins ne fasse son
sortie dans l'espace sur Gemini 10 qu'il a entraîné
abondamment dans ces courtes périodes de
zéro g
dans les premiers préparatifs pour la lune
aux atterrissages, les trajectoires de vol ont été modifiées
pour simuler les informations sur la gravité lunaire
rassemblés sur ces vols ont été utilisés pour
modifier la conception de la combinaison spatiale pour faire face aux
situations les plus difficiles
[Musique]
ces scénarios inquiétaient également les planificateurs de la NASA si
un astronaute portant son espace volumineux
la combinaison et le système de survie lourd sont tombés
serait-il capable de retourner à son
pieds
l'avion vole sur une parabole moins profonde
était capable de simuler la gravité lunaire pour
durées plus longues que le zéro g
L'illusion russe Il-76 sert de
le plus gros avion zéro gravité aujourd'hui, tel
les avions sont utilisés pour bien plus que
former les astronautes dont ils servent
Laboratoires de microgravité où
l'équipement est testé et les expériences sont
entrepris
les opérateurs proposent même l'apesanteur
Joyrides
l'Agence spatiale européenne en partenariat
avec des cannes comporte six campagnes zéro g chacune
année de vol au départ de l'aéroport de Marinyak en
le sud de la France
l'avion a300 utilisé pour ces vols
sera bientôt remplacé par un A310
l'arrière de l'avion connu sous le nom de
la zone flottante libre est rembourrée et équipée
avec mains courantes, il est équipé de
bancs pour techniques et biologiques
expériences qui sont la principale raison
pour les vols
récemment la Station spatiale internationale
a commencé à utiliser une imprimante 3D pour être sûr
qu'il fonctionnerait correctement dans
en microgravité, il a été testé pour la première fois à bord
ce vol zéro g, physiologie humaine
mécanique des fluides biologie combustion et
la physique fondamentale est parmi les plus étudiées
disciplines
[Musique]
merci
belle vallée
[Musique]
à la fin des années 1960, la NASA était
prêt à envoyer des astronautes au-delà de la Terre
l'orbite pousse fort pour atteindre la lune mais
ils prenaient des risques qui aujourd'hui
être impensable
étranger
Octobre 1968, une Saturn V commençait à avancer
en route vers le complexe de lancement de Cape Kennedy
39 tampon a
il y avait eu deux Saturne V précédents
se lance mais celui-ci Apollo 8 serait
le premier à transporter un équipage
initialement prévu comme un test habité de
le module lunaire en vol en orbite terrestre
les objectifs ont été radicalement réajustés
quand un module lunaire ne pouvait pas être prêt
avec le temps, l'équipage de conduite a également été changé
Jim Lovell était le pilote du module de commande
et bien qu'il n'y ait pas de module lunaire
Bill Anders était un lunaire désigné
module pilote
[Musique]
Frank Borman commanderait le nouveau
Missionnez les astronautes originaux d'Apollo8
ont été déplacés vers Apollo 9.
ils seraient les premiers hommes à partir
Orbitez la Terre et volez autour de la Lune et
ces astronautes avaient eu très peu
il est temps de se recycler pour cette nouvelle mission 15
14 13 12 11 10
9. nous avons la séquence d'allumage des étoiles
les moteurs sont sur quatre trois deux un zéro
nous avons un engagement
7 h 51, heure normale de l'Est
[Musique]
sur l'harmonique Saturn V précédente
les vibrations avaient provoqué l'arrêt prématuré
de deux moteurs, mesures prises pour rectifier
le problème a vu un lancement sans faille pour
Apollon 8.
11 minutes et demie après le lancement,
vaisseau spatial toujours attaché au dessus
étape atteinte en orbite avec à la fois le
le personnel au sol et l'équipage spatial entrant dans un
période intense de vérification du système
c'était une mission risquée à moins que le public
la raison avait été avancée
de la CIA
les renseignements ont suggéré que la Russie était
préparer une mission orbitale lunaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Injection AR
peu de temps après le tir de l'étage supérieur s4b
pousser Apollo 8 hors de l'orbite terrestre
vers la Lune
[Musique]
maintenant un nouveau problème est apparu Frank Borman
a commencé à se sentir malade et à vomir, ce qui
C'était encore plus désagréable en apesanteur
[Musique]
à cause de l'attitude d'un vaisseau spatial
ils ne pouvaient voir la lune qu'à travers
la fenêtre ronde, ils ont commencé à voir davantage
et plus de la terre
[Musique]
bientôt ils seraient les premiers à
voir notre planète dans son intégralité
cependant cette fenêtre s'est vite embuée de gaz
des huiles contenues dans le scellant chimique
Apollo 7 en avait également souffert
problème
alors qu'Apollo 8 s'approchait de la lune, l'équipage
préparé à une brûlure de moteur qui
placer l'engin en orbite lunaire
le moteur principal a dû tourner pendant quatre
minutes lorsque le module de commande était
derrière la lune hors contact radio
c'était la première fois que l'équipage
j'ai une bonne vue de la Lune
William et est prêt à photographier
la surface lunaire
une partie importante de la mission consistait à
documenter des zones telles que la mer de
Tranquillité pour préparer l'avenir
atterrissages lunaires
puis sur la quatrième orbite, ils ont vu
quelque chose d'étonnant oh mon Dieu regarde
cette photo là-bas, c'est la
La Terre arrive, wow, c'est si joli
après cette mission, on disait souvent
qu'ils sont allés sur la lune et
découvert la Terre
tu as un film couleur Jim
passe-moi un rouleau de questions sur les couleurs
après 10 orbites de la Lune Apollo 8
a mis le feu à son moteur principal et a commencé son
retourner sur Terre
[Musique]
lors de sa croisière de retour Bill Anders
pris plus de photos de la Terre
les astronautes d'Apollo 8 sont revenus alors que
Héros leur vol autour de la Lune avait
remettre l'espacement de la NASA au premier plan
pages
mais c'était la fin de 1968 et il y avait
il ne reste qu'un an pour atteindre la lune
dans les délais fixés par le président Kennedy
[Musique]
à peine deux mois plus tard, Russell Schweikard
Dave Scott et le commandant Jim Mcdivitt
se préparaient pour le prochain Apollo
mission
Apollo 9 serait le premier test du
système Apollo complet jusqu'à présent le
le module lunaire n'avait effectué qu'un seul vol
quand il a été testé sans équipage
ce serait la première fois deux
des vaisseaux spatiaux avaient été lancés ensemble
[Musique]
et comme toutes les missions Apollo, ce serait
bien plus complexe que la mission qui
l'avait précédé
un lancement en février avait été retardé à
le 3 mars 1969 pour permettre à l'équipage de
se remettre d'un virus qu'ils avaient contracté
même si Apollo 9 resterait sur Terre
en orbite, l'équipage a été confronté à une punition
calendrier Non seulement ils seraient les
premier à piloter le module lunaire mais un
une sortie dans l'espace avait été prévue pour tester le
nouveau système de survie autonome
[Musique]
après avoir atteint l'orbite, la commande et
module de service séparé du s4b
étage supérieur qui portait la lune
module
ils parsèment l'atterrisseur lunaire pour
retirez-le du s4b
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après la séparation, Apollo 9 a reculé vers
une distance de sécurité et Ground Control envoyé
l'étape abandonnée en route vers
le soleil
les jours suivants furent passés à
Manœuvres avec le moteur principal étant
tiré cinq fois en changeant l'orbite en
préparation aux tests de la lune
module et pour simuler à mi-parcours
Les corrections qui seraient nécessaires sur un
voyage sur la lune
l'équipage avait retiré les écoutilles et
sondes pour dégager le tunnel de liaison
entre le module de commande et la lune
module qui avait été nommé Gumdrop et
araignée, c'étaient les premiers engins de la NASA
être nommé depuis Molly Brown de Gemini 3
[Musique]
tous les aspects du vaisseau spatial lié
a été étroitement surveillé dans Mission Control
bientôt McDivid et Schweikart arriveraient
une machine qui n'avait aucune capacité de
je retourne au sol et rien
ça pourrait mal tourner
au cas où quelque chose se passerait mal et que
deux embarcations n'ont pas pu s'accoster à nouveau
un marcheur dans l'espace étant prévu pour tester un
transfert extérieur entre l'araignée et
Boule de gomme
c'était le premier du programme Apollo
sortie dans l'espace et Rusty Schweikart n'était que
relié par une attache en nylon à tous ses
l'oxygène et l'énergie électrique provenaient de
le système de survie portable qu'il portait
sur son dos
les deux vaisseaux spatiaux avaient été dépressurisés
et pendant que Schweikart était occupé au
module lunaire que Dave Scott récupérait
un échantillon expérimental de l'extérieur
du module de commande
cette sortie dans l'espace a été écourtée parce que
Schweikart souffrait de l'espace
maladie
le lendemain, une araignée et un chewing-gum tombent
séparé pour la première fois
utilisant son moteur de descente spider le
Le module lunaire s'est retiré à une distance de
environ 150 kilomètres
la prochaine fois que Dave Scott au commandement
Le module a vu le module lunaire qu'il avait
a largué son étage de descente inférieur
tous les tests moteur pour les deux étapes avaient
fonctionnait bien et la NASA développait
confiance dans leur nouveau Moon Craft
[Musique]
avant de se réamarrer avec le module de commande
mais le dividende Schweikart a fait un complexe
série de pirouettes pour permettre à Scott de
inspecter l'araignée sous tous les angles
[Musique]
quand les trois astronautes ont été réunis
le module lunaire a été largué
finira par brûler dans la Terre
atmosphère
[Musique]
ils ont passé encore plusieurs jours en orbite
photographier la Terre avant de s'éclabousser
dans l'Atlantique
La NASA n'avait plus que neuf mois pour se réunir
La fin de la décennie pour le président Kennedy
date limite pour envoyer un homme sur la lune
mais il restait encore une étape avant qu'ils
a fait la première tentative d'atterrissage
oh, la scène est sous pression, Apollo 10 le ferait
emmène un module lunaire sur la lune et
descendre vers la surface lunaire mais il
n'atterrirait pas
[Musique]
conformément aux directives très strictes de la NASA
calendrier, il y avait une longue liste de questions
de répondre et la mission aurait le
l'équipage le plus expérimenté de tous les Apollo
Mission jusqu'à présent
le pilote du module lunaire Gene Cernan avait volé
sur Gémeaux 9.
Le pilote du module de commande, John Young, avait
volé sur Gemini 3 et 10.
et le commandant Tom Stafford avait volé
Gémeaux 6 et 9.
étranger
problèmes que cette Mission a dû résoudre
était lié aux inégalités de la lune
gravitation
précédente lunaire habitée et sans pilote
les missions orbitales avaient découvert que
concentrations variables de masse à l'intérieur
la lune avait provoqué l'apparition d'orbites lunaires
erratique, la NASA avait besoin de les cartographier
irrégularités pour bien comprendre comment
leur vaisseau spatial fonctionnerait dans leur
orbite 9. nous avons la séquence d'allumage des étoiles
moteurs sur cinq quatre trois deux
moteurs en marche
défense, engagement, décollage, nous avons le décollage
29 minutes après l'heure
[Musique]
Apollo 10 serait une répétition complète
pour le premier alunissage, ce serait
le deuxième apollocraft à quitter la Terre
orbite
roues d'amarrage et extraction du
module lunaire qui avait été le principal
l'objectif des missions précédentes devenait
banal
plaisir
merde et nous y sommes, nous avons deux Gris
Roger
Apollo 18 fut le premier vaisseau spatial à
faire des émissions de télévision en couleur
et ils ont attiré une audience d'environ 1
milliard
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme lors de la précédente mission Apollo 10,
deux vaisseaux spatiaux ayant chacun besoin d'un
signe d'appel
les astronautes avaient choisi d'appeler le
vaisseau mère Charlie Brown et le lunaire
module Snoopy d'après les populaires Peanuts
bande dessinée de l'époque d'après
space Les équipages ont été invités à choisir des noms
qui avait un peu plus de gravité
[Musique]
merci
quand ils ont disparu derrière la lune
ils ont tiré le moteur principal pendant six
minutes que les astronautes ont décrites
comme étant interminable
l'engin s'est mis en orbite lunaire alors que
prévu et six heures plus tard, Stafford et
Cernan est entré dans Snoopy pour le préparer pour
descente vers la surface lunaire
il regorgeait de flocons en apesanteur
isolation en mylar qui s'était détachée
lorsque le tunnel de liaison était
sous pression
provoqué des démangeaisons pour le reste du
vol
mais il y avait plus de problèmes
Charlie Brown Houston nous sommes inquiets
à propos de ça
dans l'agneau et glissement apparent du
anneau d'accueil que nous aimerions que vous désactiviez
le module Luna avait plus de trois
degrés non alignés avec le
Module de commande et pression d'air dans le
le tunnel entre les deux engins n'a pas pu
être libéré, Houston craignait que
le désamarrage maintenant pourrait endommager les loquets
qui les a tenus ensemble
Les ingénieurs sur le terrain ont décidé que
tout ce qui est inférieur à six degrés n'était pas un
problème et Snoopy a tout donné
clair pour se détacher
fois où un module lunaire avait volé dans le
environnement lunaire pour lequel il avait été
conçu
[Musique]
Les planificateurs de la mission craignaient que
Stafford et Cernan pourraient tenter de s'emparer
la possibilité de faire une opération non autorisée
Atterrissage donc Snoopy manquait de carburant
s'ils atterrissaient, ils ne pourraient pas revenir
[Musique]
pour les huit prochaines heures John Young
je serais seul dans Charlie Brown
[Musique]
Houston terminé
c'est génial, ça a l'air génial, nous avons copié
Snoopy est tombé de plus en plus bas en passant
directement au-dessus du site d'atterrissage proposé
pour la prochaine mission Apollo et
voyageant à plus de 500 kilomètres de
le vaisseau mère
mais juste avant qu'ils ne soient dus
largage La Descente étape un guidage
le commutateur de réglage était dans le mauvais mode et
le module lunaire a commencé à tourner sauvagement
en vidant l'étape The Descent et
passage à la commande manuelle Tom Stafford
a pu retrouver sa stabilité
[Musique]
mais ils avaient une giration sauvage, mais
ils l'ont sous contrôle
[Musique]
le Rendez-vous s'est déroulé comme prévu
et Apollo 10 est resté en orbite lunaire
pendant encore 29heures pour cartographier les anomalies
dans la gravité lunaire avant de retourner à
La terre
mais même s'ils étaient près de la Lune
un autre ensemble et cinq avaient été déployés
à la rampe de lancement
Apollo 11 était en préparation pour le
première tentative d'alunissage
étranger
l'agence spatiale lance un moyen léger et
des fusées lourdes depuis ses installations de
Guyane française mais il n'a pas la capacité de
ramener des véhicules à travers la Terre
atmosphère pour un atterrissage en toute sécurité
le véhicule expérimental intermédiaire ou
ixv est en cours de développement pour qu'Esa puisse
Maîtriser les techniques de contrôle
rentrée depuis une orbite terrestre basse
l'ixb utilise le concept de corps de levage dans
combinaison avec de la céramique et du carbone
protection thermique des fibres
bien que ce soit une technique plus complexe
que le bouclier thermique ablatif commun
en résine plastique qui se dissipe
chaleur en se vaporisant Esa veut tester un
véhicule qui offre un meilleur contrôle pour
plus de précision à l'atterrissage
le véhicule concept fonctionnera
de manière autonome
équipé de propulseurs pour maintenir le
attitude correcte avant d'atteindre le
l'atmosphère terrestre
en descendant à 120 kilomètres le ixv
rencontre les niveaux supérieurs du
Ambiance à ce stade, c'est un voyage
à une vitesse approchant 27
000 kilomètres par heure
deux vérins plats maintiennent l'engin
correctement aligné pendant cette partie de
les rentrées là-bas sont sans réponse
questions sur cette partie du voyage
avec les molécules d'oxygène et d'azote
dans l'air devient une température élevée
plasma qui n'obéit pas aux habitudes
règles d'aérodynamique
à une altitude de 26 kilomètres le
l'engin aura ralenti à 1600
kilomètres par heure où le premier d'un
la série est un parachute supersonique est
déployé
bien que cette technologie soit bien
j'ai compris qu'ASA devait encore effectuer un drop
essais en Méditerranée d'un mannequin
ixv pour voir comment leur vaisseau se comporterait
[Musique]
à la mi-2014, l'engin a été préparé pour
son vol depuis le port spatial européen
au Karoo
le ixv a été couvert dans plus de 300
capteurs pour surveiller son comportement pendant
Toutes les phases de son vol de deux heures
Oh
il faudra six mois avant le
les données techniques ont été parfaitement comprises
et peut être utilisé dans la conception d'un
véhicule de rentrée plus grand
[Musique]
depuis plus de 15 ans, l'Europe est
travailler sur sa propre navigation par satellite
système appelé Galileo, le système est
conçu comme un emplacement mondial civil
service comme alternative au
GPS américain doté de fonctions militaires
applications
cela signifie que les utilisateurs moyens de GPS peuvent avoir
leurs serveurs rétrogradés sans préavis
une phase de validation en orbite utilisant quatre
satellites a été récemment achevé et
de nouveaux ajouts sont lancés
régulièrement jusqu'à une constellation de 30
les satellites sont en service
les satellites 5 et 6 connus sous le nom de dorisa et
Malena a été envoyée le 21 août 2014
à bord d'un lanceur Sawyer
au début, tout semblait avoir disparu
bon mais un défaut de conception dans la frégate
l'étage supérieur a permis aux conduites de carburant de geler
pendant la croisière prolongée et le
des satellites ont été livrés à Elliptical
plutôt que des orbites circulaires
un moment juste pour trouver où dorisa et
Milena était là, puis le personnel au sol a commencé
les calculs détaillés impliqués dans
rendre les satellites utilisables
postes
l'extrémité inférieure de l'orbite a pris les deux
satellites via le Van Allen
ceintures de radiations mettant en danger la
Electronique de navigation sensible
en utilisant les propres manœuvres du satellite
propulseurs ils ont été rendus utilisables
orbites circulaires après systèmes exhaustifs
chèques Theresa et Melena ont reçu un
état de santé impeccable et bien que leur
les postes ne sont pas idéaux, ils le seront quand même
pouvoir contribuer au Galileo
fonction des constellations
bientôt les deux prochains satellites Adam et
Anastasia entrera en orbite bien que
leur lancement a été retardé par un
examen approfondi des Sawyers et de ses
accès gratuit à l'étage supérieur
il a été déterminé que le
proximité d'une ligne d'hélium froid avec le
la conduite de carburant a causé le problème de gel dans
l'obtention gratuite
[Musique]
prêt
alors que le programme Apollo se préparait à
atterrir sur la lune, c'est en quelque sorte
début d'un âge glorieux de
Exploration Pendant que d'autres le voyaient
comme la fin d'une fuite coûteuse sur le
Budget américain
d'accord
tôt le 16 juillet 1969, en grand nombre
se rassemblaient le long des plages de
Le centre de la Floride, témoin de l'histoire
le peuple américain se préparait
pour ce moment depuis presque une décennie
depuis que le défunt président Kennedy avait
répondu aux premières demandes de l'Union soviétique
supériorité dans la technologie spatiale par
organiser un voyage sur la lune en tant que ressortissant
but
plus d'un million de personnes se pressaient
les routes et chaussées autour du Cap
Canaveral, récemment rebaptisé
Cap Kennedy
des dignitaires mineurs et des amis et
les familles des travailleurs de l'espace avaient accès à
stands spéciaux construits dans le
terrain du Centre spatial Kennedy pour
voir les astronautes d'Apollo 11 décoller
alors que le public avait une grande confiance en
La capacité de la NASA à faire atterrir des hommes sur la Lune
les experts travaillant dans l'espace
les entreprises mettent leurs chances de succès
pas mieux que 50 50.
merci
les astronautes avaient passé de longues heures dans
des simulateurs se préparant à chaque
éventualité mais l'équipement qu'ils utilisent
pour la pratique uniquement à condition d'avoir
approximation des conditions dans l'espace
avec certains des bancs d'essai apparaissent dans
Bazar
un portique spécial construit à la Nasa Langley
à condition que quelque chose se rapproche du
expérience de la gravité lunaire
merci
heures avant le lancement prévu, le
le géant Saturn V prenait lentement du carburant
ses réservoirs seraient constamment remplis
jusqu'à quelques secondes avant le décollage
[Musique]
Michael Collins était le module de commande
pilote qu'il avait déjà piloté sur Gemini
dix.
Buzz Aldrin était le pilote du module lunaire
il avait été le pionnier de nouvelles techniques pour l'espace
marcher sur Gemini 12. pour s'assurer que le
la fuite a été corrigée et la mission
Le commandant était Neil Armstrong sur Gemini 8
sa tête froide et sa rapidité de réflexion l'avaient
a sauvé la mission de la tragédie
Apollo 11 aurait une expérience pleinement expérimentée
équipe choisie pour traiter et résoudre
problèmes difficiles
et il y aurait des problèmes
chaque mission de la NASA avait construit sur le
expérience des missions précédentes mais
il y avait toujours un moment où ils
est entré en territoire inconnu et le
pression pour atteindre la lune avant le
la fin de 1969 avait été implacable
[Musique]
mais le peuple américain était suprêmement
confiants et des soirées de lancement ont eu lieu
à travers le pays
étranger
[Musique]
ERS n’a pas tardé à capitaliser sur l’ambiance
de célébration
le bras oscillant revient maintenant comme notre
le compte à rebours continue au Kennedy Lodge
La tension centrale était élevée chez le né en Allemagne
fusée Pionnière Verna Von Braun son tout
la vie avait mené jusqu'à ce moment
ci-dessous nous avons un technicien une équipe de
des techniciens travaillent tout le monde au cap
compris combien de composants différents
devait fonctionner correctement pour réussir
les astronautes du lancement ont convenu que le lancement
les rendait le commandement de tir le plus anxieux
j'arrive maintenant
ce serait le sixième lancement du
Booster Saturn V et tandis que certains d'entre eux
les vols avaient été un peu grumeleux, ils étaient tous
considéré comme réussi
Le guidage G moins 15 secondes est interne
12 11 10 9 la séquence d'allumage démarre
[Musique]
étranger
quelques secondes seulement après le début du vol, les commandes de vol étaient
transféré de la salle de tir du
complexe de lancement vers Mission Control en
Houston
[Musique]
12 minutes après le lancement, Apollo 11 était en
orbite terrestre basse en dehors d'une légère
difficile avec la troisième étape
tout avait été routinier
deux très faibles pouvez-vous nous donner un statut
rapport s'il vous plaît
injection translunaire et amarrage avec
le module lunaire étaient désormais des pratiques qui
cela avait été fait plusieurs fois auparavant et ils
aussi ont été réalisés sans problème
étranger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la croisière vers la lune et l'orbite lunaire
avait été fait deux fois auparavant et le vol
les manuels et les listes de contrôle avaient tous été
Réécrit avec le bénéfice du précédent
expérience
[Musique]
le système Apollo avait été conçu pour
que toutes les informations de navigation et
Les brûlures du moteur pourraient être effectuées de manière autonome
par l'équipage mais les techniques de télémétrie
s'était amélioré si rapidement que la mission
le contrôle donnait maintenant toutes les instructions
cependant l'équipage a quand même utilisé le
technologie pour déterminer leur position
en cas de problème de communication
Les pilotes du module de commande étaient fiers du
précision de leur navigation
[Musique]
les modules de commande et lunaires étaient
équipé du guidage Apollo
ordinateur l'un des premiers outils pratiques
micro-ordinateurs
pour la plupart des calculs, il y avait un manuel
solution de contournement mais pour le vol complexe
chemin requis pour que le module lunaire
atterrir sur la lune, l'ordinateur de vol était
essentiel
vivant
attends maintenant en orbite lunaire, l'équipage de
Apollo 11 perdrait le contact radio tous les
la fois où ils sont passés derrière la Lune
[Musique]
lors de la 13ème orbite le module lunaire
séparé du module de commande
les deux embarcations sont désormais adoptées individuellement
les indicatifs d'appel du module de commande sont devenus
Columbia et le module lunaire étaient maintenant
aigle
la descente sur la Lune s'est produite en trois
étages séparés chacun contrôlé par son
propre programme informatique
la première étape était la phase de rupture
qui a changé l'orbite pour qu'elle atteigne
une zone au-dessus du palier d'atterrissage désigné
indiquer
pendant cette période, l'équipage était
voyageant les pieds en premier, regardant le
Terre
la prochaine étape était la phase d'approche
quand l'aigle s'est renversé dans un plus
attitude verticale
c'est à ce moment-là qu'Aldrin et Armstrong
leur première vue du point d'atterrissage
une longue région elliptique dans la mer de
La tranquillité était leur objectif à l'air libre
l'avion a été jugé comme l'endroit le plus facile
pour le premier alunissage
maintenant des choses inattendues ont commencé à se produire
le carburant dans les réservoirs des Landers lunaires a commencé
se balader alors que ce n'était pas le cas
dangereux, le mouvement signifiait l'engin
ne pouvait donner aucune indication claire sur son
Site d'atterrissage préprogrammé
le 1202
donnez-nous une lecture sur le programme 1202
alarme
puis l'ordinateur de vol a commencé à sonner
une alarme et il n'y avait qu'une seule personne
dans le contrôle de mission, je savais ce qu'était un 1202
l'alarme était
un jeune ingénieur logiciel a compris le
l'ordinateur était surchargé mais il
pourrait encore s'occuper des soins critiques
les fonctions
la mission continuerait Roger nous avons
toi, nous partons en alarme
[Musique]
la dernière partie de la séquence d'atterrissage
était toujours contrôlé par ordinateur mais
a permis au commandant d'ignorer le
Le taux de descente de l'engin et son
positionnement alors qu'il se dirigeait vers un
champ de gros rochers qu'Armstrong a pris
contrôle à la recherche d'un
aire d'atterrissage
étranger
[Musique]
ça a pris beaucoup plus de temps que n'importe qui
attendu
875 pieds, les gars ont l'air bien en bas de la moitié
direct
le carburant était faible 60 secondes
python
j'en ai trouvé deux et demi
avant
40 pieds plus bas, deux et demi pour ramasser
une certaine profondeur
30 pieds deux et demi sous une grande ombre
loin en avant
je dérive un peu vers la droite
Je pense qu'une livre et demie 30 secondes
d'accord
lumière de contact
ok moteur arrêter APA lors d'une défense
contrôler à la fois la commande automatique du moteur décent
remplacer
puis arrête le bras
413 est en relief dans Mission Control
C'était palpable, nous te copions vers le bas de l'aigle
Wilson euh
Base de tranquillité ici la cheville a
une fusée a atterri Tranquillité sur laquelle nous vous copions
le terrain où tu as un tas de gars
pour devenir bleu, nous respirons à nouveau
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
merci
à cause des distractions pendant le
Descente, personne n'avait une idée claire de la
Localisation exacte de l'aigle
après que l'engin ait été sécurisé,
Le plan de vol demandait aux astronautes de
dormez un peu mais Armstrong et Aldrin
a demandé un changement qui a été accepté
ils ont commencé à préparer leur marche sur
la surface lunaire
merci
[Musique]
environ sept heures plus tard, Armstrong était
descendre l'échelle
[Musique]
une caméra de télévision en noir et blanc était maintenant
activé et dans le monde 600
des millions de personnes regardaient
c'était quelque chose de nouveau que personne n'avait
je pensais que l'histoire serait télévisée
avec le monde comme témoin
on avait même avancé que la télévision
c'était une perte de temps maintenant la NASA était
reprogrammer les missions futures afin que leur
les astronautes marcheraient sur la Lune dans
Heure de grande écoute
Armstrong et Aldrin ont passé deux heures et demie
demi-heures sur la surface lunaire et beaucoup
de cette époque était utilisé lors des cérémonies
des tâches telles que planter le drapeau américain et
discuter avec le président
le voyage de retour en orbite lunaire s'est déroulé
en douceur d'ici les trois astronautes
étaient de nouveau parfaitement compris
sol
la croisière de retour de trois jours sur Terre s'est déroulée
une période calme avant une tempête de
obligations publicitaires qu'Apollo 11
les astronautes ne s'étaient pas préparés à
[Musique]
Armstrong Aldrin et Collins étaient destinés
dans les défilés de téléscripteurs à travers les États-Unis
États puis à travers le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le généreux financement des contribuables qui avait
maintenu le programme spatial était maintenant en
doute et la NASA était désireuse de s'appuyer sur cela
vague de popularité
mais dans les couloirs des questions de pouvoir
ont été interrogés sur les sommes considérables
nécessaire pour envoyer des hommes sur la lune
avec le dernier atterrissage de la navette
Flotte en 2011 aux États-Unis un important
contributeur à l'International Space
La gare dépendait de la Russie pour le ferry
astronautes vers et depuis l'orbite
Laboratoire
trois deux un zéro
mais pour acheminer du fret et des fournitures vers l'ISS
La NASA a signé des contrats avec l'espace privé
entreprise technologique SpaceX
[Musique]
La capsule cargo de SpaceX connue sous le nom de Dragon
livre régulièrement du matériel
et consommables en orbite depuis 2012.
le dragon peut aussi revenir d'orbite c'est un
tremplin vers le Dragon de l'entreprise
capsule d'équipage version 2 qui pourra
pour emmener des astronautes vers et depuis l'espace
[Musique]
doit effectuer son premier vol habité en
deux ans dont le dragon profite
nouveaux matériaux et technologies à découper
le coût du vol spatial
il est renvoyé à travers l'atmosphère
utilisera un bouclier thermique ablatif
et la génération actuelle de dragons
retour en parachute conventionnel
technologie
mais la nouvelle capsule utilisera du propulsif
technologie de décélération pour faire un
Pinpoint Landing lui permettant d'être
réutilisé
[Musique]
le Falcon 9 lance deux étages
retourner également au sol pour réutilisation
démonstrateur de technologie sauterelle réalisé
son premier vol en 2012.
SpaceX a mené une série de
vols expérimentaux de lancement et de retour
sur son site de test à McGregor Texas
le véhicule en a fait huit avec succès
des vols pour affiner le retour autonome
technique
la technologie a été incorporée dans le
Falcon 9. après le lancement d'un cargo
le premier étage du booster tente de
retourner sur une plateforme océanique
Les techniciens de SpaceX sont conscients que
des améliorations supplémentaires sont nécessaires
en 2006, l'Agence spatiale européenne a lancé
travailler sur un mappeur d'étoiles unique qui est devenu
connue sous le nom de Gaïa
conçu pour orbiter autour du Soleil à un point 1,5
millions de kilomètres au-delà de la Terre, ce sera
faites pivoter le balayage de notre galaxie locale pour
recueillir avec précision des informations de position
sur les étoiles voisines
deux télescopes différents fournissent des images à
les sondes de très grande haute définition
caméra
au cours de sa période d'exploitation de cinq ans
Gaia analysera à nouveau les mêmes zones 70 fois
lorsqu'il tourne autour du soleil, sa position
le changement lui permettra d’observer
Différences de parallaxe à partir desquelles précision
les distances des étoiles peuvent être déterminées
en plus de la position et de la distance
informations Gaia collectera deux
différents types de données spectrales
on aidera à déterminer le Stellar
la vitesse de l'objet et l'autre
indiquer le fabricant chimique de l'objet
Gaia a été lancé avec succès au
fin 2013 et fonctionne
correctement puisque
son pointage et son positionnement sont
réalisé par des propulseurs à azote froid qui
ne compromet pas les performances du satellite
intégrité thermique
la liaison de données de Gaia avec la Terre peut gérer
trois mégabits par seconde et ce sera
retour sur le terrain le plus sensible de l'ESA
stations à Sombrero Espagne et Nouveau
nausées en Australie occidentale
[Musique]
merci
oh belle vallée
[Musique]
la première lune en grande partie cérémonielle
l'atterrissage était terminé et comme la NASA l'était
préparer les missions scientifiques
les politiciens préparaient d’importantes coupes budgétaires
le programme spatial
étranger
[Musique]
vers la fin des années 1960 en Amérique
j'avais enfin quelque chose à célébrer
Armstrong Aldrin et Collins avaient
revenu sain et sauf de la Lune
[Musique]
pour l'Amérique, la décennie avait commencé avec
une réalisation inconfortable
L’adversaire de la guerre froide que l’Union soviétique avait
une avance considérable dans la technologie spatiale
les États-Unis avaient été saisis par un
vague de paranoïa anticommuniste
[Musique]
neuf ans et 17 milliards de dollars plus tard
Apollo 11 avait planté le drapeau américain sur
la surface de la Lune
[Musique]
Pour toute l'humanité
sur la planète, 600 millions de personnes avaient
regardé à la télé
[Musique]
la population mondiale regardait
l'histoire et ils le savaient
attirer
ainsi qu'à Houston, pouvons-nous vous avoir tous les deux
sur la caméra
chaises et rivières dans le centre de la Floride
des millions d'Américains étaient venus voir
le lancement d'Apollo 11.
Le 14 novembre 1969 fut une journée pluvieuse à
le centre de lancement Kennedy
[Musique]
numéros qui se sont avérés regarder le
le lancement d'Apollo 12 était passé
les deux tiers
étranger
nombre de spectateurs attirés par Apollo 11
La NASA a amélioré tous les aspects du
couverture télévisée pour le reste
alunissage
Pete Conrad commanderait la mission
avec la recrue Alan Bean et le module de commande
pilote Dick Gordon
[Musique]
leur destination l'océan des tempêtes
juste à côté du site d'atterrissage de l'arpenteur 3
l'engin sans pilote qui avait atterri
deux ans plus tôt
[Musique]
tous les moteurs en marche s'engagent
arrêt 11 h 22, heure normale de l'Est,
la pluie battante n'a pas été considérée comme un problème
bien que des vents violents pourraient retarder un lancement
la Saturn V était un véhicule tout temps
et les conditions humides n'étaient pas un facteur
j'ai une photo
midi après le décollage, la foudre a frappé
Apollo 12 et a descendu le système ionisé
piste d'échappement jusqu'à la tour de lancement
tout dans le monde a abandonné
Roger, j'ai toute l'instrumentation dans le
Le module de commande s'est détraqué et la télémétrie
les lectures au sol montraient
ordures
Houston essaie de devenir auxiliaire pour
bien sûr, tant que personne dans l'engin n'est allumé
le sol savait ce qui n'allait pas
finalement, on a demandé à l'équipage de retourner un
obscur interrupteur de réinitialisation que seul Alan B connaissait
là où c'était, tout a été restauré
l'instrumentation et la mission pourraient
continuer
[Applaudissements]
gars
J'ai un bon jeu S2 Roger, nous copions Pete
tu as l'air bien, c'est arrivé à
une période critique du vol propulsé
Mission Control était très proche de
ramper et abandonner
ta poussée semble bonne Pete le
une seule orbite terrestre a été consacrée à la vérification
tous les systèmes avant qu'Apollo 12 ne soit donné
tout est clair pour aller sur la Lune
élément de droite, les piles à combustible ont l'air bien en bas
ici
[Musique]
audiences pour la mission lunaire Apollo 11
mission la NASA avait équipé Apollo 12 de
une caméra couleur pour que le public autour
le monde pourrait voir une meilleure qualité
photos de la surface de la Lune
étranger
le deuxième alunissage a bénéficié
grandement des changements de conception dérivés de
l'expérience Apollo 11
chicanes à l'intérieur du carburant du module lunaire
les réservoirs ont empêché les ballottements indésirables qui
avait confondu l'ordinateur de vol
[Musique]
L'atterrissage s'est déroulé exactement comme prévu avec
les astronautes reconnaissant tous les
points de repère à proximité du
La sonde Surveyor 3 entre là-dedans
est-ce que Pete Conrad a grimpé vers la lune
surface aux États-Unis, il était 6
un mardi matin et très peu
les gens regardaient la télévision en direct
des photos
les audiences des téléspectateurs étaient importantes pour la NASA
ils savaient garder le contribuable américain
à côté était une partie importante de
convaincre les politiciens que l'espace
le financement généreux de l'agence devrait être
entretenu
alors qu'Alan Bean rejoignait Conrad sur la lune
surface, il a attrapé la caméra de télévision pour
je l'ai déplacé et je l'ai pointé par inadvertance
au soleil
[Musique]
étranger
c'étaient les derniers programmes TV d'Apollo 12 en direct
photos de la Lune
le Pinpoint Landing est d'autant plus long
reste sur la lune et le plus grand volume
des échantillons de retour ont tous été réalisés sur Apollo 12 a
succès technique mais la NASA avait voulu
garder le public américain engagé avec
le programme spatial et les seules photos
tout le monde a vu des captures de courts métrages
Les Américains se désintéressent de l'espace
après le retour d'Apollo 12, il y avait
encore huit autres lancements de Saturn V
véhicules en production suffisamment pour s'étirer
jusqu'à Apollo 20.
mais en janvier 1970, Apollo 20 était
annulé et bientôt le prévu Apollo 18
et 19 missions ont également été abandonnées
alors que la NASA se préparait à récolter le
avantages de l'ingénierie spatiale et lunaire
recherche, le programme était réduit
les choses changeraient légèrement pour Apollo
13. La NASA a reprogrammé la mission lunaire
activité qui coïncide avec le visionnement principal
temps à travers les États-Unis
cela coûterait de l'argent aux réseaux de télévision et
ils n'étaient pas contents
Le commandant Jim Lovell avait survolé
la Lune comme pilote du module de commande sur
Apollon 8.
ce serait son quatrième vol spatial
ses collègues étaient tous deux pour la première fois
astronautes
le pilote du module lunaire était Fred Hayes
mais le troisième membre de l'équipe avait
viennent de l'équipe de secours, juste trois
jours avant le lancement
Pilote du module de commande Jack swigert
a remplacé le membre d'équipage d'origine Ken
Mattingly qui avait été exposé à l'allemand
Rougeole
Mattingly a regardé le lancement depuis
Contrôle de mission à Houston
une séquence d'allumage a commencé six cinq
quatre trois deux un
son objectif sur la lune était le loin
Morrow Highlands nommé d'après le
cratère Fra Morrow adjacent et c'est
vidé la tour
pendant le vol propulsé un deuxième étage
le moteur a coupé plus tôt les unités restantes
brûlé un peu plus longtemps pour compenser
mais ce n'était pas grave
problèmes
[Applaudissements]
L'injection lunaire se déroule sans problème et le
l'équipe a rapidement sorti sa télévision couleur
Caméra pour divertir les gens
Terre
mais à part les gens de Mission
Contrôler que personne ne regardait la télé
les réseaux n'ont pas réussi à diffuser le
transmission envoyée depuis Apollo 13.
[Musique]
alors nous avons encore un article pour vous
quand tu as une chance, alors nous y parvenons
ils, euh, remuent vos réservoirs cryogéniques
peu de temps après qu'ils eurent cessé leur
transmission avec le vaisseau spatial trois
quarts du chemin vers la Lune et
L'explosion a emporté le module de commande
alimentation principale
personne n'a compris ce qui s'était passé mais
il est vite devenu évident qu'Apollo 13
je n'allais pas sur la Lune
restez prêt à 13 heures, nous l'examinons
[Musique]
avec le module de commande effectivement mort
l'atterrisseur lunaire est désormais devenu le
la seule source d'énergie de l'astronaute
son moteur de descente servirait à tous
Corrections de cours
le vaisseau spatial a continué à circuler
la Lune sur une trajectoire de retour libre
c'est un site d'atterrissage sur l'Atlantique
un débarquement dans l'Atlantique Sud
récupérez-les le plus rapidement mais il n'y en avait pas
navires de récupération dans cette zone
avant qu'Apollo 13 ne disparaisse derrière le
Le personnel au sol sur la Lune a commencé à recalculer
la brûlure qui ramènerait l'engin à
l'océan Pacifique
alors qu'il y avait assez de nourriture et d'oxygène
pour durer jusqu'au retour à l'eau de la terre
et le pouvoir serait critique
avant de longues températures dans l'engin
était tombé presque au point de congélation avec
de l'eau strictement rationnée, Fred Hayes a reçu un
infection urinaire
le plan était de rétablir le pouvoir au commandement
Module utilisant uniquement les batteries de rentrée
avant qu'ils n'atteignent l'atmosphère terrestre
cela n'avait jamais été fait auparavant, donc un
équipe d'experts dont Ken Mattingly
commencé à expérimenter différents
procédures dans un simulateur
[Musique]
Le programme spatial de la NASA était de retour
gros titres mais pas pour les raisons pour lesquelles ils
recherché
simulations de la séquence de mise sous tension
étaient compliqués à cause de la condensation
causée par les basses températures dans
Le module de commande a menacé de court-circuiter
le système électrique
finalement une procédure a été radio vers le
équipage
[Musique]
le sauvetage a montré le meilleur de la NASA
résoudre de manière créative des problèmes difficiles
ils se sont levés et
ok d'accord Roger est efficace merci
vos caméras, bien, Shepherd était celui de la NASA
premier homme dans l'espace grâce à son Mercure
la capsule Freedom Seven n'avait volé que pendant
15 minutes, il était destiné à devenir un
partie importante de l'espace américain
Programme
en 1964, on lui a diagnostiqué la maladie de Ménière
maladie et suspendu de tout vol
activités
a passé le programme Gemini en tant que chef du
bureau des astronautes
après une chirurgie correctrice, il a été restauré
au service de vol et a finalement été fait
commandant d'Apollo 14.
son pilote du module de commande était Stuart
Russe
et le pilote du module lunaire était Ed
Mitchell
L'objectif d'Apollo 14 était de faire frire Morrow le
même zone dans les hautes terres lunaires que
avait été la cible de l'Apollo avorté
13. ce serait le dernier du type h
missions qui ne transportaient aucun véhicule quatre
trois deux un zéro
Enfin, trois minutes après l'heure
après presque 10 ans, Alan Shepard était
de retour dans l'espace peu de temps après Apollo 14
atteint l'orbite, son temps de vol spatial était
doublé
comme toutes les missions Apollo précédentes, il
serait plus complexe que celui qui
l'a précédé contrairement à toutes les missions Apollo
il y aurait des problèmes
[Musique]
l'amarrage avec le module lunaire devrait
c'était une routine mais à cette occasion
le mécanisme ne se verrouille pas
cinq tentatives, toujours sans succès
à la sixième tentative, Stu Russo a fait un
utilisation plus agressive de ses propulseurs et
les deux engins verrouillés ensemble
[Musique]
en orbite lunaire après le module lunaire
Antares s'est séparé du vaisseau mère
Kitty Hawk L'ordinateur d'atterrissage a commencé
faire clignoter une alarme
[Musique]
le commutateur d'abandon avait un fonctionnement intermittent
court qui déclencherait un automatique
séquence d'abandon si cela s'est produit pendant le
étape motorisée de la descente d'Antarès vers le
surface
contrôle d'admission bien qu'ils ne puissent pas
réparer l'interrupteur qu'ils ont décidé de reprogrammer
l'ordinateur pour qu'il ignore le
fausse alerte, ils avaient deux heures pour
élaborer le nouveau code
c'est le programmeur du MIT, Don Isles, qui
a trouvé une solution de contournement
la nouvelle séquence a été testée dans un
simulateur puis les 61 frappes
requis ont été lus aux astronautes
Le Débarquement s'est déroulé avec Point pénal
précision
le module lunaire avait atterri sur un sept
degré d'inclinaison qui a fait bouger dans le
camping difficile, ils étaient environ un
kilomètre du bord du cratère du cône
où ils devaient récupérer
des échantillons durant cette seconde guerre mondiale
comme pour chaque lune Apollo réussie
Mission d'atterrissage des astronautes non remplie
le drapeau américain
avant Apollo 11, il avait été proposé
que le drapeau des Nations Unies soit planté
mais le Congrès avait adopté une loi stipulant
qu'aucun drapeau autre que les étoiles et
Des rayures pourraient être déployées
lors des précédentes missions lunaires
les astronautes avaient expliqué comment
il était difficile d'évaluer les distances et
reconnaître des points de repère
Shepard et Mitchell étaient fatigués pendant
leur montée vers le bord du cône
cratère
[Applaudissements]
surveillance du contrôle d'admission du médecin
leur fréquence cardiaque s'inquiète
ont reçu l'ordre de revenir sans s'en rendre compte
ils n'étaient qu'à 20 mètres de leur
objectif
mais la NASA était sur le point d'éliminer cela
problème
Les astronautes d'Apollo s'entraînaient avec un
nouveau morceau de matériel, tout reste
les missions pourraient voyager 10
fois plus loin du module lunaire
utiliser le nouveau rover lunaire
la géologie était la caractéristique principale de
missions Apollo restantes
une analyse préliminaire montrait que
la lune avait autrefois été fondue avec des roches
ne contenant aucune trace d'eau
Dave Scott commanderait Apollo 15. Jim
Irwin était le pilote du module lunaire cette
ce serait son premier vol spatial
Al Warden était le pilote du module de commande
Apollo 15 était aussi son premier espace
vol
améliorations dans la conception de la Saturn
V lanceur et améliorations du
paramètres de ciblage et de trajectoire
signifiait qu'une version plus lourde du
le module lunaire pourrait désormais atteindre la lune
porter des charges plus lourdes
[Musique]
les nouvelles missions élargies s'appelaient J
missions
non seulement ils pourraient en apporter davantage au
Lune, ils pourraient apporter une plus grande masse de
Roche lunaire retour à la Terre
[Musique]
leur cible sur la surface lunaire était
Headly réel un groove sinueux particulier
probablement formé par d'anciennes roches volcaniques
activité
Le site d'atterrissage était sur la Lune
Hémisphère Nord près des Apennins
montagnes
séparation du module lunaire Falcon
du module de commande a été retardé par un
problème de trappe mais cela a été vite résolu
Les techniques d'atterrissage étaient désormais si raffinées
que Scott a pu facilement compenser
pour une aberration précoce de six kilomètres
et posez Falcon pour un autre Pinpoint
Atterrissage
[Musique]
la qualité des images télévisées de
la Lune avait continué à s'améliorer à mesure que
publics à travers les États-Unis
diminué
la grande différence était le rover.
cela permettrait seulement aux astronautes de
voyager plus loin et transporter plus d’échantillons
mais sans se fatiguer Scott
et Irwin utilisait moins d'oxygène et pouvait
rester plus longtemps en surface
Dave Scott avait pris sa géologie
formation très sérieusement et sur le
deuxième traversée lunaire de l'équipage
rover, cette formation a payé
ils ont découvert un rocher blanc au
bas du rail Hadley qui était
on pense qu'il fait partie du substrat rocheux lunaire
il est devenu connu sous le nom de Genesis Rock et
c'était vieux de plus de 4 milliards d'années
après presque trois jours sur la lune
Scott et Irwin ont préparé le Falcon pour
retour en orbite lunaire
[Applaudissements]
automatique
il n'y a eu que quelques petits problèmes
au cours des premières parties de la mission
et Rendez-vous à quai et les équipages
retour sur Terre a continué à rester
Sans problème
lors de la descente finale, le reste
carburant hautement corrosif des capsules
les propulseurs ont été largués mais cette fois
provoqué l'effondrement de l'un des
Les trois parachutes du Craft sont encore endommagés
ça aurait été catastrophique
étranger
[Musique]
Au début de 1972, il n'y avait que deux
missions Apollo restantes malgré le
les expéditions lunaires se multipliaient en
durée et complexité l'américain
les gens avaient perdu tout intérêt, tout comme
Administration politique
des difficultés potentiellement mortelles sont survenues
à chaque vol mais la NASA l'avait été
bon pour surmonter les problèmes que le
le drame de l'exploration lunaire était facile
poussé hors des premières pages par la guerre et
scandale politique
[Musique]
quand la dernière mission sur la lune
décollé la nuit aux heures de grande écoute
Les chaînes de télévision ont été ennuyées par ce lancement
les retards ont gâché leur programme de visionnage
l'astronaute Jean Cernan serait le dernier
l'homme de marcher sur la lune et avec le
retour d'Apollo 17 sur Terre Luna
l'exploration s'est arrêtée, il n'y a aucun plan
retourner sur la Lune
[Musique]
merci
vraiment incroyable
la navette spatiale a été conçue comme un
moyen économique de se rendre à
routine en orbite terrestre basse mais la promesse